au match de speech qui va opposer
icaruna camira à anial Sarine petite
seconde faut que l'échiquier s'ouvre
ah bah voilà les filles qui est ouvert
parfait est-ce qu'on va avoir la partie
je pense que oui et on va suivre ça
tranquillement
et ben voilà c'est parti c'est parti
pour ce match je vais essayer de
rajouter le chronomètre
et on va être au top
donc on est dans la cadence 5 plus
simple pour le moment
on a le timer avec nous il va falloir
que je les affiches à l'écran
voilà on a tout affiché et c'est pas les
quarts de finale c'est les demi
et ben voilà c'est parfait
écoutez j'espère que ce sera un match
sympa bon j'espère une victoire de
Sarine mais voilà ça va dépendre de
ça va plus dépendre du carreau qu'autre
chose alors attendez pourquoi est-ce
qu'on est décalé ouais ok ça c'est bon
et je pense qu'on est bon je pense qu'on
est tout bon je vais ouvrir le chat je
pense qu'on sera pas très nombreux pour
ce match mais c'est pas
c'est pas important
on va regarder ça tranquille on va tout
bien mettre
pour que ce soit agréable et on va
espérer quelques surprises quelques
petites victoires de
denial Sarine pour essayer de mettre un
peu de suspense après il sera pas
beaucoup moins fort en belette
on verra pas grand monde même sur la
chaîne américaine pour le moment encore
on attend nous ici en français plutôt le
match de demain mais ouais c'est sûr que
c'est pas une affiche qui attire les
foules ça farine en demi-finale ça fait
pas rêver quand même je sais pas combien
il est au classement mondial
les sympas ce match quand même ouais
j'aurais préféré ne pas le voir sur
internet celui-là dorylo sur ishiki réel
il m'aurait plus plus intéressé ce match
là à titre personnel il y a des matchs
comme ça tu te dis ah tiens sur
échiquier
je préfère
ouais demain demain il y a une belle
affiche pour nous et puis bon surtout à
la fin du mois championnat du monde de
Blitz et rapide
mais ouais c'est plus des affiches ça
que tu aimerais voir sur eshi Réal quand
tu as des joueurs un peu moins forts
comme ça qui ont jamais vraiment peur
sur sur vrais Chiki
tu préfères
par acquis de conscience
que ce soit sur vraie échiquier pour pas
pour pas avoir un doute qui te reste en
tête après
ça c'est logique
tu vas jouer avec l'idée sur dame
français c'est pas très c'est pas très
dur à voir ce que je l'avais
mais ouais il faudrait il faudrait
il faudrait une victoire de
Niall Sarine
comme ça Maxime il aurait la voix la
voix royale ouverte
ça ce serait vraiment une bonne chose
dans des je suis en train je vois qu'il
y a pas le
il y a pas le son mais je sais comment
le rajouter c'est un petit bug
de Windows
qui va être réglé très rapidement
bon là la position est pas claire pour
le moment si les blancs réussissent à
frapper ça va être bien pour eux sinon
ça va juste être égal
parce que c'est une option ou je sais
pas ça on va laisser car oui penser moi
j'ai un peut-être un coup comme je sais
pas je regarderai pas perso mais
je pense qu'il calculait plutôt cavalier
prend des 6 pour apprendre des six dan
BE4 quelque chose comme ça qui aurait pu
être fort
il a joué dame B4 il menace dame prend
des 6
donc là il va falloir défendre
donc cavalier 4
[Musique]
qui a été deux
mais peut-être un Racing co qui va
partir maintenant et pour chasser la
dame
qui joue dame B3
qui prend des deux il veut reprendre des
deux
et sur A4 il revient en B4 avec la dame
bon on va voir on va voir ce que ça joue
on va voir ce que ça joue de toute façon
il y a plus qu'à attendre maintenant les
dés sont jetés
c'est mieux aux blancs moi je sais pas
c'est compliqué c'est dur à dire les
blancs un problème de développement
quand même au final
donc il prend il fait à 4 D4 tour il
doit vouloir dames C2 roi-1 mais il a
pas plus d'échec que ça il y aura des
six attaqués et peut-être qu'il
reviendra après on sait six
mais il Caro qui va pas pouvoir dominer
dans son style habituel peut-être c'est
peut-être ça qui l'inquiète
ce que d'habitude il gagne vraiment
énormément sur la tactique qui Caro
et là peut-être qu'il pourra un peu
moins gagner sur la tactique
va sûrement damser de tout racisme et
puis après Maxime on verra pour la
finale il faut déjà battre Carlson
faudra qu'il joue mieux qui hier quand
même Maxime pour gagner contre Carlson
ce qu'on avait un saut quand même hier
dans des dans des conditions assez
particulières et assez difficile
et ça aurait et ça aurait pu mal se
passer quand même qu'il faudra jouer
quand même un peu plus fort
donc il a joué fou prend 4 puis on prend
le 4 dames prend 4 ça ça va être joué
probablement fou eux deux et surtout ces
deux il y aura cavalier C3 j'imagine
mais il y a aussi du dame prangée de
possibles donc on va voir
c'est pas clair
en tout cas Ico et peut-être dominé dans
cette première partie
il a fait roi des ouais qui est plus
safe
qui remet un échec croyant elle seule
couche je suis étonné qui Caro
réfléchisse alors là c'est très bizarre
comme réflexion
parce que Revin c'était vraiment le seul
coup les gars
parce qu'il doit vouloir se dire
peut-être est-ce qu'il veut faire pas ou
pas
bon là c'est grosse question pour NiAl
normalement il a l'avantage autant une
bonne position enfin je sais pas si il
est mieux ou pas mais il a une position
qui peut se jouer
tu prendrais quand même nulle
personnellement parce que l'attaque peut
vraiment s'essouffler on peut se
retrouver perdant très vite
je partirai plutôt pour nul quand même
si j'étais si j'étais ni à le Sarine
mais après j'ai pas sa capacité de
calcul donc il peut il peut trouver des
choses intéressantes mais j'ai
l'impression qu'on bloque un peu pour
terminer cette attaque
ouais c'est la décision qui est prise à
des sciences semble logique on sent à
roue petite tête
allez ça fait pour le moment un demi
mais une partie assez offensive de la
part de Sarine
c'est un gambida m'a accepté
clairement l'ouverture c'est le la phase
de jeu qui peut créer le plus de
problèmes à Sarine d'après moi
on sait même pas d'après moi c'est c'est
juste une évidence si Caro et nettement
mieux préparé et on avait vu en dans le
Global chas championne chips que ça
avait déjà été un problème à l'ouverture
globalement pour
pour NiAl donc c'est la phase de jeu
dans laquelle il faut qu'il trouve des
positions jouables et s'il trouve
quelque chose de jouable déjà au blanc
ça suffira à mon avis pour pour son
bonheur
qui reste encore une heure 20 dans cette
cadence
à jouer puis après il y aura une heure
en trois plus un et 30 minutes en 1 + 1
le match devrait terminer aux alentours
de 19 heures
quel qu'en soit le score
donc là c'est une position assez typique
des gambidas acceptés
avec les pions qui sont échangés en dés
en C qui laisse une position
symétrique en termes de structure mais
un petit avantage de développement au
blanc et un plan classique dans ces
structures c'est de ramener le fou en F3
pour venir taper sur la case B7
il y a une menace ici pour les blancs
c'est fou point F6 d'imprime 4 c'est
l'idée de cavalier F3 je suppose
et donc il va falloir reprendre de G
j'imagine
plus fort mais le début de match
évidemment est très important
plus ça reste tendu
le plus longtemps ça reste tendu le plus
compliqué peut devenir le match
c'est ça de bon ça va se développer
la normalement on aimerait bien mettre
les tours en D1 C1 et la dame en A1 mais
c'est assez long et difficile à réaliser
donc peut-être qu'il va décaler la dame
en E2 plutôt
et mettre les tours sur les colonnes on
voit que la dame noire est venue sur
cette belle case E7 c'est une case sur
laquelle il y a pas trop de vis-à-vis
en tout cas pour le moment car vous
domine pas autant il joue pas plus vite
que son adversaire si vous êtes attentif
à ce facteur
c'est un facteur qui peut être
déterminant parce que là encore c'est
une case à cocher pour NiAl dans ce
match
la case du temps et pour le moment c'est
une casse qui coche il est en train de
faire tout ce qu'il faut faire dans ces
deux premières parties pour avoir une
chance de gagner alors après peut-être
que ça ne suffira pas et c'est même
probable mais s'il va avoir une chance
de l'emporter ça doit ça passe par ces
choses là
donc là il a joué 5 Hikaru
toujours un coup à double tranchant
parce que ça ça prend de l'espace mais
ça en laisse derrière
il n'y a qui laisse pas
on voit qu'il tout saute un petit peu
il est sur un petit ordinateur portable
sur un petit bureau de fortune
ça a pas l'air giga confort génial
il doit avoir l'habitude c'est
finalement sa maison
je suis quand même étonné de l'écart
autant que NiAl réussit à imposer
jusqu'à maintenant
il a fait fou B6 soit il tape un il tape
sur la diagonale et cette tour Fd1 qui
peut laisser des cavaliers G4 peut-être
la case des 5 pour nia alors ouais mais
bon la case des 4 pour i carreau enfin
ça c'est un peu con de dire ça quand
même chacun a sa case ici c'est
symétrique comme comme structure donc
personne n'a davantage
de structure de pions
il fait fout B3 ça a l'air d'être un
coup assez intéressant
parce qu'il veut jouer peut-être
cavalier C4 pour toucher le fou et taper
le pion
j'ai l'impression de que kikaru
n'est pas super content de ce début de
match c'est vrai qu'il a l'habitude de
débuter en fanfare et faire tout de
suite très mal
et là c'est pas le cas
c'est pas le cas pour le moment
NiAl s'accroche fort
et j'ai même envie de dire que là dans
les deux premières parties c'est plutôt
lui qui mène au point jusqu'à maintenant
après tu auras des 8 salaires d'être un
excellent coup sur cavalier C4 il veut
aussi en fait
c'est très bien joué je pense de la part
du carreau
le cavalier sera peut-être un peu
bizarre
par contre j'ai pas la rêve sur X 2 ah
mais peut-être qu'il veut tout reprendre
des reins et décaler la tour en D1 et le
on réussit pas vraiment protéger le fou
proprement
c'est quand même un peu trop j'ai
l'impression on peut pas se priver de
cette colonne D comme ça
et décaler le fou peut-être à l'avancée
de
je pense c'est une belle séquence de
coût du carreau tu auras des 8 fois ici
peut-être qu'il va devoir quand même
accepter d'échanger les les funials
il peut y avoir aussi des soucis avec
des cavaliers G4 un moment donné qui
arrive
en tout cas là il a réussi à le mettre
en danger
c'est bien fait de la part du joueur
américain
ignal qui se retrouve mal au temps
maintenant une 38 contre une contre 2-08
ça y est il a réussi à le mettre en
légère difficulté
attention à ça peut être un premier
point qui en appelle d'autres
il fait H3 donc il veut éviter tout un
tas de cavaliers G4 dans des variantes
ça a l'air d'être plutôt un coup correct
par rapport à tout ce qu'on imaginait
le temps extrêmement important contre
Ricardo mais bon il se laisse quand même
pas non plus distancer puisqu'il avait
une grande avance il avait 45 secondes
d'avance il s'est repassait un peu
derrière mais il se laisse le temps de
terminer la partie
ça continue à tout sauter
des cadres qui est joué par Ikaru qui
vient
s'infiltrer sur la belle case
il joue toujours sur ce clouage
alors est-ce qu'il va prendre en D4 il
en est pas obligé il peut aussi jouer
juste un coup comme tour C1 mais il peut
y avoir des déviations des prisons 4
c'est compliqué
NiAl qui est peut-être entré dans un
truc trop tactique là
ça y est qui a l'air de se détendre
bah forcément prendre le match au
sérieux il y a pas un tel écart
elle a le fout des quatre a l'air de
faire Malika roux sur de sa force
ça fait de la petite grimace à 7
il décide de tout échanger cavalier à 5
sur foupend B3 il va faire cavalier
prend évidemment et quand il perd 4 il
récupère des quatre
minutes maintenant pour essayer de
trouver un coup
pénible
il n'y a pas vraiment de B6 à cause de
cavalier c'est 6 qui prend des 8
avec des jolis rebonds
sur dame C7 il y a tout raté un
donc on peut pas venir se placer sur la
colonne C
après de b6k et C6 ça peut se calculer
parce qu'il y a des fous prométron
intermédiaires et pourrait faire c'est
pas moi B6 qui est c'est 6 dames D7 qui
a aidé 8 vous prend B3 par exemple donc
sur quoi sur B6 qui est ici date de 17
on pourrait jouer aussi mais il pourrait
peut-être prendre ses 6 et jouer cette
position en essayant de récupérer au
cadre derrière
ça me paraît quand même compliqué de se
lancer là dedans plus de 36 secondes
pour Hikaru qui a un petit peu de temps
qui espérait peut-être trouver un gain
mais qui l'a pas
il fait pousser 8 du coup
tranquille mais qui menace rien le 5 qui
envoyait qui est des 5
pour prendre des quatre il veut
cavaliers C3 tu reprends des 4 qui avait
lieu deux qui prend des quatre
20 secondes pour y aller il va falloir
cliquer maintenant
peut-être qu'il va être obligé de jouer
vous prend pour prendre et F4
il se décide pas assez vite NiAl là il
s'est foutu trop dans la merde
il fait dame F3 il touche le cheval
cavalier C3 il doit vouloir tourter 3
mesdames prend le 5 il a pas vu
peut-être juste
il a peut-être juste craqué
bah ouais c'est juste un punto trop fort
et carreau le match va être long
à moins qu'il revienne très vite dans le
match ça va être long parce que j'ai
l'impression qu'il carreau
va juste dominer les faces très
tactiques et comme ils ont le même style
ça risque d'être très facile pour le
streamer américain aujourd'hui
c'est juste cavalier quoi trop menace à
Tours et menace maintenant H1
carreau qui joue H3 donc il a juste
décidé de troll tellement c'est facile
peut-être mécontent la première
ouverture
mais trop fort et carot dans la phase de
calcul
ouais il faut vraiment très tranquille
c'est
c'est une leçon
à toi et moi j'ai raté le premier coup
il en a rien à [ __ ] car en fait
terrible
c'est terrible
[Musique]
le match va être long
à mon avis en plus si ça joue en troll
comme ça ça a pas grand intérêt en fait
je trouve en tout cas personnellement
que ça tue un peu l'intérêt des matchs
on voit du coup que c'est pas du tout
sérieux en fait
et que de par ce format très long les
joueurs peuvent se permettre quand même
quand il y a un écart de
troll un peu comme ça
non en fait c'est ça qu'il faut que je
change
il jouera pas comme ça au championnat du
monde de Blitz je vous rassure
il avait pas joué comme ça au candidat
non plus hein
il était au contraire
ultra bien préparé
mais ouais ouais c'est
difficile
j'espère qu'on va pas avoir un match
comme Carlsen kerwana bon ça
je sais pas comment dire mais tu as le
match d'hier avec un joueur qui est dans
des conditions loin d'être normal pour
jouer
ceux qui nous a quand même offert un
beau combat mais bon il y a pas
il y a pas une équité totale dans le
dans les conditions de jeux entre les
deux joueurs tu as eu le match tu as
celui-là ouais c'est difficile c'est
complexe
OK
il va quand même être mieux ouais le
match risque d'être compliqué
pour ça
au finalikaro était très bien préparé
ouais pour les candidats il a dû il a dû
payer quelques
excellents secondaires et préparateur
là ouais ça va je sens que ça va être
dur après je peux me tromper encore mais
je sens que que ça va être très
compliqué pour y aller
c'est qui le champion en titre de speech
c'est un cas
c'est Caro
juste une dernière dépôt et Ding au
dernier candidat ouais exactement non
peut-être il a fini 4e finalement
ça te coûte combien en euros une bonne
préparation aux candidats
je sais pas tu as dans les 200 250 000
euros je sais pas j'ai pas d'idée
tu as des joueurs qui ont même plus de
budget
c'est dur à dire je sais pas je peux pas
te répondre comme ça la question mais
très très bien préparé pour les
candidats c'est plusieurs centaines de
milliers d'euros
être vraiment pour être vraiment dans
les top top top top
est-ce que s'il y a peut-être des jeunes
bah si les champions des chèques une
carrière de joueurs d'échec au top
généralement c'est enfin tu arrives
normalement au top top vers 22 23 ans
bon ça fallait ça enfin entre 22 et 25
ans on va dire ça fallait résa qui est
arrivé lui plus tôt et tirer jusqu'à
35 38 ans donc ils sont jeunes ouais
après tu es juste trop vieux hein
il y a rien d'étonnant
cerveau il marche moins vite avec l'âge
qui avance
comme ça un jeu fondamentalement basé
sur la vitesse de calcul
ah non de l'exception ouais bon tu as
toujours une exception mais on va pas
prendre une exception pour faire une
règle quoi
mais ouais
donc non ils sont pas spécialement
jeunes ni vieux ils ont un âge normal
pour pour du sport
mais les Blancs ont l'air bien
juste un pion de plus en fait
et si tu as mis leur développement ils
vont être très bien
en longue c'est un porte peu la vitesse
de calcul non au contraire ça joue
quasiment que là dessus
vu que c'est qu'un jeu de calcul celui
qui calcule le mieux et le plus vite bah
c'est le plus fort
ma dernière façon c'est les mêmes
joueurs qui sont bons en longue quand
globalement à deux trois exceptions près
mais qui pourraient se corriger c'est la
même chose
bon il a son pion de plus central il est
forcément nettement mieux
après plus qu'une 19 il faut être précis
quand même
sera net favori quand même
généralement il domine le match up
je pense que le pour Carlson c'est
plusieurs de battre mvl que Hikaru mais
après on verra
alors que Ikao contre my sims c'est
peut-être 90 10
voir même 95 5 à tel point
ikawa de bons résultats contre Maxime
alors que Maxime contre Carlson c'est
peut-être 35 65 ou 40 60
c'est beaucoup plus serré
c'est les histoires de style
correspondant
vu la dernière fois il sera 5 plus
préparé pour un match j'ai l'impression
que Magnus là maintenant qui joue plus
championnat du monde il donne aussi plus
d'importance à ces tournois là donc il
sera
il sera plus fort que
il y a quelques années ouais
c'est drôle que le match up c'est aussi
important dans un jeu information
complète bah ça dépend des styles en
fait c'est comme tout
voilà c'est vraiment pion de plus hein
c'est
il y a pas de compensation en réalité
pour les Noirs alors c'est pas facile à
jouer pour les blancs mais il y a pas de
compensation c'est plus qu'il y a des
pièges
mais il n'y a pas de compensation à
proprement parler si les Blancs jouent
concrètement les bons coups il y a pas
de problème
ok ouais c'est assez pion de plus et il
va y avoir F4 F5 F6
on a un peu vibrotté les deux premières
parties parce qu'on s'est dit tiens il y
a pas encore deux heures facilement
mais là je crois que le score va rentrer
petit à petit
alors attention à ce cavalier qui peut
être en prise mais le pion F des qui va
partir il va faire mal
il peut même caler un dame F3 s'il a
envie pour taper F7
il fait j'ai 5 qui sécurise le cavalier
regarder ce centre qui bloque
complètement tout le jeu noir
trop facile et carreaux
il aurait eu beaucoup plus de mal contre
Ding liren
allez il va juste développer son fou en
F4 j'imagine
il va laisser la tour en prise c'est pas
très grave puisque il a ramassé une
pièce au passage et là c'est peut-être
dame C3 dame français 4
et ça fait déjà deux points d'écart
ouais ça va à mon avis ça va être très
très lourd Hikaru qui va juste Farm en
fait
il y a un bug là à mon avis de REMAX on
voit pas la partie à paraître
ouais ok petit bac de connexion d'un des
deux joueurs mais ça fait déjà deux
points allez on part pour trois points
d'écart let's go
ça rejoue ce gambida m'a accepté
organiser le record de Carlson en car
après je pense pas que ça arrive il est
quand même plus jeune que que je pense
pas qu'il a autant le match
ça réfléchit en tout cas à côté
NiAl
c'est peut-être mieux
final demain
à 19
si dans l'ouverture par le fouet 2 qui
est plus fort à mon avis
c'est pas mal joué ça d'avoir pris des
quatre et fait X à 3
mais mon tour c'est de la main il va
quand même réussir à se placer
parce que ça me prend en longue je pense
mais bon
bah des trucs auxquels je joue pas aussi
donc
si on soit pas très intéressantes je
calcule pas c'est sûr que c'est pas
évident
de toute façon il suffit juste de
regarder les lots en fait tu veux savoir
qui est plus fort entre deux personnes
juste check le hello à la fille
c'est en fait le plus simple
ce que femme ça c'est moins clair je
sais pas
ok intéressante
je suis même pas sûr
tu mets le fond aussi si tu as quand
même la paire de fou la dame est
complètement coupée de la loi donc tu
attaques pas le roi et un moment donné
tu fais cinq quatre
le problème c'est plus le pion à 6 en
fait
il y a quoi qui permet de vérifier la
triche rien
pas évident là
pas évident à jouer au noir c'est pas
sûr qu'il soit réellement moins bien
mais c'est dur à jouer
parce que Caro a déjà trouvé ça je
répondrai pas à ces questions là
si c'est genre de choses vous intéresse
vous pouvez
vous renseigner par vous-même sur
internet même si pas toujours évident
rien
[Musique]
là je pense qu'il est pas bien il a
quand même ce pion noir ici il a fini
par tomber
mais je me demande toujours sur quelle
couleur les pions
ça dépend des positions c'est la
personne qui va te dire sur quelle
couleur vont les pions
c'est une erreur de beaucoup d'amateurs
qui pensent qu'il y a des
des formules secrètes pour bien jouer
aux échecs des trucs qui marchent à
chaque fois c'est vrai que c'est les
vidéos YouTube qui marche le mieux
d'ailleurs mais en fait ça marche pas
comme ça
c'est un peu du charlatanisme de vouloir
faire marcher ça comme ça il y a des cas
qui marchent plus souvent que d'autres
mais là par exemple c'est dur à dire
normalement les pions ils veulent pas
trop bouger pour le moment mais ça
dépend ce qui va se passer peut-être ce
sera F4 peut-être ce sera 4 ce sera rien
ça va plus être là du concret qu'autre
chose en fait
la dame A6 elle est bizarre elle est
enfermée mais on peut pas la choper
parce que sur fousser 8 il y a dans 6
c'est peut-être pas le seul coup mais
ça j'ai l'impression qu'il y a des
cavaliers H5
il veut peut-être monter en G6
je pense pas quand même mais pour jouer
avec tour B6 après
ça se peut qu'il y a les gagne ça là ce
serait bien pour garder de l'intérêt
dans le match
qui permet de jouer sur le clouage
d'aller en à 8
et poussez vite tu aurais aussi dame C6
d'ailleurs on réussit pas de toute façon
enfermer complètement la dame mais c'est
juste que s'il faisait dames enfin en
fait on échange on fait B4 en B6 tours
la finale elle doit quasiment aller
bon la Sarine histoire absolument
réussir à convertir
ni contre ricarous c'est pas facile
OK
pas simple à conclure en fait pas simple
d'avancer et que les dames sont
échangées il y a B4 et on aura un pion
qui en arrête 2
à cause de la prise en passant
et si on fait pas d'âme c'est 6 c'est
dur de monter
c'est pour ça que c'est aussi dur de
batterie carreau
donc là il va faire F4 et mettre le fond
c'est 5
tu vas faire cavalier F5 peut-être
champion prend
bam B6 pour pousser 5 après
ça à quatre prises prises pour B2 ouais
je pense ça va être nul quand même
elle est trop fort et Caro
il défend extrêmement bien il est très
fort en tactique donc il défend très
bien
et ça rime qui en fait une nouvelle fois
les frais
en plus il a des petits problèmes de
connexion NiAl vous voyez pas mais il a
que trois barres de connexion sur chess
com
ce qui en plus va pas lui faire mal pour
le moment 5+1 ou 3 + 5 mais qui peut
faire une petite différence en belette
j'imagine qu'il va monter le ranger ici
si Carouge c'est chose faite
ouais donc en plus avec du lag ouais
c'est quand ça arrive au joueur le plus
fort c'est gérable mais quand ça arrive
au joueur qui est moins fort c'est dur
26 secondes chacun
ça devrait clôturer par une nulle cette
partie
il se fait clôturer la tronche
allez carreau plus que 23 secondes
roi G5 est intéressant d'ailleurs ici
pour venir taper sur le fou
c'est le coût de l'ordi Sarra G5
alors il a prié F3 ah il veut
complètement enfermer le cheval je vous
le gars en fait ikaro
ah ouais c'est terrible c'est peut-être
très mal joué il a raté ton Detroit
ouais ça se voit il a raté le coup
petite scories dans le jeu il caresse
donc là il a toujours son pion de moi et
la position est ultra extrêmement
complexe
il fait F6 plus que trois secondes pour
Yaro
ce qui clique toujours aussi vite je
vous mets en belette qu'avant ouais on
voit ça par contre c'est terrible la
guerre
il va pas être bien là
pour ranger 7 prises 3G 6 il va perdre
l'option B3 et ça c'est nul
et ça c'est juste nul
est-ce qu'il a pas tourbé 6-3 G4 ah oui
il va lui faire échec il va suivre le
roi avec roi F3 menace maths
mais on voit qu'il a un Sarine
on voit qu'il aille à certains moments
donc ça va être très très compliqué
ouais bah si en plus des problèmes
d'internet ça va faire trop
il reste il reste encore une game avant
la pause où ils font la pause maintenant
il affront après
et toi non pas avoir fait une position
là on continue un peu à troll un côté
côté IKK dans les ouvertures
ouais bizarre d'habitude ils font la
pause quand ils restent 46 minutes
tu Collonges cette ouverture bon ça a
pas de nom mais c'est retourné dans une
chicorne avec les blanches je dirais
j'appellerai ça une si gorille avec les
Blancs ce qui a fini par arriver mais
avec le fou en C1 complètement de la
merde mais pourquoi pas
pour vérifier si le tricher ou non et
quand sonne seulement lui tenait tête
avec l'ordi mais la même battue non j'ai
pas vu ça
donc je peux pas réagir à cette histoire
de manière directe je sais pas ce
qu'elle est vrai ce qui est sûr c'est
que pour moi une personne
qui se mettra à tricher
pour vérifier si l'autre ne triche pas
est un tricheur aussi et devrait être
interdit bien évidemment à vie de jouer
et ça pour moi c'est évident parce que
frère t'inquiète j'ai fait juste pour
essayer pour pour voir si l'Autriche ou
pas oui bon enfin c'est extrêmement
gentil mais bien évidemment ça s'appelle
tricher aussi et ça se met au même
niveau que la personne en face
mais après comme je disais je peux pas
réagir au fait que nepo l'ai fait ou pas
parce que j'ai pas la rêve de la vidéo
mais sinon ça s'appelle juste être un
gros tricheur une grosse merde en fait
donc
si tu as la vidéo n'hésite pas à me la
transmettre mais oui ça ferait de cas de
dépôt
un tricheur en fait vêtement
sinon c'est trop facile enfin
t'inquiète frère je faisais exprès pour
test non mais bon enfin c'est très
gentil
Cyprien jusqu'à mon préalable va jamais
accepter une chose pareille à moins que
cheescom veuille le faire pour coincer
un tricheur
ce qui serait une autre chose mais
ce serait le seul cas où ce serait
viable
si tu le dis pas avant et que tu le fais
de ton propre chef
c'est que c'est que tu as un tricheur en
fait point barre
mais n'hésitez pas à assurer la vidéo ça
m'intéresse sur ce genre de truc
je sais regarder
t'inquiète frère je regarderai les
meilleurs coups pendant les parties non
non évidemment ne faites absolument
jamais ça de votre côté c'est évidemment
simplement être un tricheur que de faire
ça
peu importe
juste pour vérifier non mais c'est
exceptionnel c'est juste vérifier frère
si déjà tu sais le faire parce que moi
je saurais pas comment faire
de manière comme ça intuitive je
pourrais pas allumer un ordi pour
vérifier en même temps j'aurais pas le
temps de cliquer de ma rentrée les coups
ce serait impossible
donc rien que si tu es en capacité de
vérifier ça veut dire que c'est un
système que tu as déjà utilisé d'une
manière X ou Y en fait c'est il y a pas
de par un moment donné tu dis juste je
vais vérifier pendant la partie c'est
pas tu as pas le temps
ça c'est un peu comme si tu as si ta
femme te trompe et
et genre non non on est allé au resto
pour parler à faire
un collègue de travail
je sais pas ouais c'est juste pour
essayer en fait oui bon
très gentil mais
c'est pas ce que tu crois ouais
d'ailleurs c'est très étonnant on le
sait pas ce que tu crois c'est que ça
anticipe déjà ce que tu es en train de
croire quoi
mais bon ce que tu es en train de croire
c'est pas très catholique en fait
pas très catholique ce que tu crois
mais du coup on s'est toujours pas si la
vidéo est vraie ou si le mec invente en
fait
mais ça a quand même permis de remettre
une
de reposer une base
ma position est pas claire depuis tout à
l'heure
c'était vraiment vrai
échecs quand même beaucoup de joueurs
même de premier plan qui trichent était
pas vraiment au courant
donc c'est pas sûr dans les échecs il y
a une vraie tolérance vis-à-vis de la
triche pas surprendre du parler
ce matin
non il s'est levé ce matin mais il s'est
pas dit ça
pions des 4 ouais puis on des quatre
bien au noir en fait parce que ce pion
des 4 il est quand même un peu affaibli
la dame A6 allait bien placée
les cavaliers aussi
complexe
ça rime à comme une minute d'avance et
une bonne position il a que des bonnes
positions j'ai l'impression qu'il
Carouge ou vraiment tranquille ou
il est loin d'avoir
mis en route son mode Super Saiyan ni
carreau
il est même pas en super ça il y en a
encore
Ikao il a encore deux trois modes plus
fort que ça
il joue extrêmement tranquille
et Sarine réussit toujours pas en gagner
une c'est dire le niveau du loustique
vous avez changé ma vivement donc il
prend des pour dévier la tour
et là sur pion oui carreau qui a raté ça
les champions
B2 tours G7 il y a pas mal
bon après je pense c'est pas le seul
coup mais ça veut dire que c'est un
problème
donc il va quand même prendre
ah mais FG tout reprend B2 il y aura G8
mat
ok donc ils peuvent faire il peut faire
tout reprend E2 FG non tu reprends le
dos autour des 8 3 7 FG tu reprends B2
G8 maths
OK
un peu de bol parce qu'il avait pas vu
ça de basico
ça c'est quelque chose qui l'avait raté
et du coup sur dame prend E2
surprend et G4 et peut-être tourner 8 G5
et jouer sur le roi à la barbe un peu
bizarre
ok c'est pas clair
déjà presque à une heure de jeu ça passe
vite
génial qui a laissé passer peut-être une
nouvelle occasion
pas de bol
comment tu sais qu'il avait raté parce
que on a vu à la caméra qu'il a fait un
petit truc comme ça qu'il était dègue et
finalement il l'a vu dans un deuxième
temps
donc ça c'est simplement vu avec
l'information de la caméra
les mimiques d'icaro oh là il a un truc
joli la damage 4 cavaliers H5 et tout
rache 8 x 5 dames français 4 après ce
qu'il a joué ça a l'air pas mal aussi
quatre peut-être pas mais il a peut-être
raté le tour à chute 5 c'était peut-être
gagnant
il peut pas tout voir tout le temps il
envoie déjà tellement heureusement qu'il
est encore humain
mais là la position est quand même belle
sur F6 il doit vouloir dame j'ai 4
autour des 7 dame 4 et ce qui menace
quelque chose ah si le Fou se décale il
aura de 5
et surtout des 7 il doit vouloir rager 7
et
sur il veut tout recettes ok il suit la
tourelle
ça va faire nul pas de bluff non pas de
nul
car ou peut-être en petit danger ici
à mal placé cette tourelle ouais B5
c'était faute
trois secondes escavalier est tellement
fort H4 c'est bien joué
cavalier 7 aussi
pleutre
mais éclairé quand même
bien joué de la part de NiAl
qui va peut-être pouvoir la gagner
celle-là
c'est 7 les Punto H5 puis on prend roi
prend tout F4 tours
terrible
c'est terrible le roi est coupé
et le roi va pouvoir revenir sur le
Punto
terrible
qui aura tout donné dans cette game
mais c'est pas assez ça va nous amener
vers la première pause
car il fait semblant qui joue le gain
pour économiser quand même un peu de
tempo
et c'est la première pause qui part
niale qui aura raté ces occasions quand
même les carreaux qui est tellement
facile
il est tellement facile
quand même de bien dominer après
c'est fou tout ce qu'il pleut ici aussi
tu as trouvé la vidéo Ludwig ah ouais
mais si tu triches du triche
c'est hallucinant en fait
ouais c'est un peu embêtant quoi
non mais enfin allumez son ordi pour
tester un joueur ça s'appelle enfin ça
n'existe pas ça Ludwig hein c'est
tricher
c'est enfin j'ai en fait c'est on va
gagner tous les titles et puis après
c'était pour tester
non mais c'est juste triché mais c'est
fou le ce que je vous disais aux échecs
c'est vraiment
la proportion de la triche elle est
vraiment hallucinante en fait
c'est hallucinant en fait à quel point
les joueurs ont pas de scrupule
hallucinant donc c'est pour ça qu'au
bout d'un moment tu as un peu un
désintérêt aussi des commentateurs des
tournois parce que quand tu te rends
compte de ça au bout d'un moment quand
tu le sais
il est encore un bouton vous savez
beaucoup moins que moi
bon c'est terrible
allez ça repart
avec farine
et les pièces blanches
toujours la même ouverture
bon
je vais finir de manger moi en même
temps tranquillou
mais les fous n'est pas pour moi il
devrait être bandes mais c'est pas mais
elle doit être ancienne la vidéo non
mais bien sûr il était même invité au
speechasse donc ça pose pas problème
elle date de 2 semaines
ok mais normalement tu dois être bannes
en fait
de tous les sites de jeux si tu triches
tu triches
c'est comme je vous dis en fait le truc
c'est que j'ai triché pour voir si
l’autre tricher en fait rien que pour
savoir tricher faut avoir enfin c'est
pas si simple de tricher en fait c'est à
dire que tu as pensé que tu as utilisé
ton système autrement
tu réveilles pas d'une seconde à l'autre
en sachant comment tricher quoi c'est
pas si simple en fait c'est pas
compliqué mais c'est pas si simple
ah bon
évidemment il y aura rien il y aura
aucune sanction qui sera prise je vous
rassure
c'est comme avec Carlson ou quoi quand
un certain niveau il y a plus de
sanctions tu fais ce que tu veux
mais ouais c'est un peu c'est un peu
c'est un peu bizarre
ouais après façon sans doute
comme je vous dis depuis longtemps en
fait l'ampleur du problème elle est
encore plus grande que ce qu'on pensait
c'est
stratosphérique en fait
c'est stratosphérique
mais ouais c'est pire des gens nous on
pensait que c'était grave mais en fait
ça dépasse encore ce qu'on pensait
ce qui est extrêmement flippant
bon
position toujours mieux pour les blancs
mais plus agréable mais pas forcément
mieux
[Musique]
mais cinq jours en responsable
mais après il y a des choses qui ont été
faites récemment sur la triche sur
chaise comme il y a une amélioration
mais après c'est un peu toujours les
seconds couteaux qui tombent quoi mais
il y a des choses qui sont faites
clairement
le seul
difficulté entre guillemets c'est que
les joueurs du top niveau un genre
d'immunité
mais ça finira bien par changer un jour
son plus dur à rattraper parce qu'ils
sont plus forts donc ça leur profère un
genre d'immunité
ils ont un totem d'immunité ouais
en fait il y a clairement encore plus de
problèmes au top niveau mais juste ils
sont il y a pas il y a pas de modèle
pour les attraper en fait
pas mal quand même NiAl mais il arrive
pas à frapper quoi
et des trois c'est logique
il vient retaper sur la case C5
du coup on comprend la glaçon de
Carcassonne face au tricheur après il en
fait lui-même partie donc c'est un peu
problématique aussi quoi
qui adopte ma position de main contre
max Lagarde ça m'avait pas réussi ouais
ça avait pas réussi qu'on ne backing non
plus
en tout cas ça réfléchit
côté Hikaru
c'est proche de proche des gammes mais
c'est chiant à jouer pour les noirs
comme ça je sais pas ça le fait marrer
je pense qu'au début c'était pour se
donner un style et que à force il est
devenu la caricature
de lui-même en le faisant tout le temps
en x 3
il y a peut-être se faire enfermer le
fou
et
tourbé un ça va être joué pour protéger
béca 4
[Musique]
je sais pas ce qu'il veut peut-être à 5
et B4 mais
on va voir comment ça continue peut-être
à 5 et B4
ça a l'air bien
peut-être pas tout de suite il joue en
quoi avant mais après et là il a poussé
encore du coup
il va peut-être la gagner ça la farine
c'est en tout cas c'est la
c'est le titre de position qui a réussi
le mieux mais il manque peut-être de
temps et de connexion à la fin
OK
position est tellement dur pour les Caro
mais il défend bien ce genre de position
qu'il aurait du mal à défendre Magnus
peut-être cavalier des trois maintenant
mais encore cavaliers C4 pour cailler
des deux
il va pas réussir à la gagner NiAl
il est tellement proche mais j'ai
l'impression qu'il carreau va s'en
sortir
il est tellement proche mais le fou a
plus de vie qu'un Nico
c'est incroyable ce qui défend de pas se
faire choper le fou sur autant de
coussins incroyable
et maintenant il va faire [ __ ] par
c'est incroyable
c'est trop
c'est beaucoup trop
c'est beaucoup trop fort surtout
et là maintenant avec très peu de temps
on va voir
si un des deux joueurs réussi à
l'emporter
carreau qui veut pas faire nul encore
pour le moment
il y a le Sarine non plus
voilà maintenant sans les cavaliers ça
va se simplifier
non c'est les blancs qui pressent de
nouveau un tout petit peu
sur Hikaru qui fait de la merde
mais juste
il est juste assez attend pour la tenir
il y a ici quand même un peu à avancer à
la pousser
allez faut qu'il l'attende celle-là oh
ça ça s'appelle une tourelle
et ça fait Eric arrow mais iris jaune là
il est pas ouais
ça le fait pas rire en fait ce que je
veux en fait il a des grimaces qui fait
assez souffré qu'amant
là il y a un bug qui fait que ça relance
pas immédiatement je pense
ce que je vois les joueurs un peu
riche jaune c'est un peu raciste c'est
pas une expression française rire jaune
c'est incroyable quand même la bêtise du
chat parfois
Noël là ça ça bug en fait pour les
rematch et c'est vrai que c'est en
faveur des carreaux puisque ça permet de
temporiser l'oeil joue plus les
ouvertures trolls
on va voir ce que NiAl a opposé dans ce
gambidam pas s'il va prendre du cavalu
ou du pion il prend du Punto
il va tout prendre 4
peut-être et grand rock
ça doit aller ça pour les Noirs je pense
il y a le pion isolant des quatre
évidemment qui est une force et une
faiblesse
à la fois mais je pense pas que le roi
noir soit vraiment en danger
et à faire dames et 7 sur dame C2 il
fera H6
puis va placer ses tours au centre et
jouer C5
peut-être oursin c'était bien joué mieux
jouer que damso
il y a pas de réponse
c'est la question je me posais en fait
ça joue sur le clouage
ça dégoûte NiAl en fait toutes ces
tactique
il y en a trop
c'est pas facile à jouer
ça donne l'impression qu'il peut pas
sauver de son pion en fait
de la merde pour le moment il joue des
ouvertures trolls il a joué à H3 au
premier coup
il est très facile après il a dit
lui-même les matchs sont tellement longs
il a le temps mais
clairement le format de pas très envie
de se décarcasser direct quoi
il a dit lui-même avec les
que les matchs étaient trop longs c'est
sûr que 4 heures comme ça quand tu es
joueur
pas très très motivant non plus
[Musique]
le saumon ouais en demi
en fait ils sont 7 oui
même des matchs de tennis mais si c'est
en termes de temps et que les points
s'enchaînent et qu'on compte juste les
points j'ai du mal à imaginer ouais
ouais Maxime en très grande forme après
l'objectif soit pour Maxime à l'irza et
tout le monde c'est quand même déjà la
Championnat du Monde c'est rapide à la
fin de l'année mais surtout la
qualification prochain candidat c'est un
peu ça qui compte au bout d'un moment
donc on verra
il y a deux ans quand il avait bien joué
au speechs Maxime ça s'est enchaîné
par un vaikanzi désastreux et une non
qualifié et une non-victoire aux
candidats et l'année dernière quand
Maxime a très mal joué au speedchait ça
s'enchaîné par un titre de champion du
monde de Blitz
donc c'est bien de bien jouer les c'est
sûr mais je veux dire que
ouais faites l'année
où il a très bien joué ça c'est ça le dé
par de très mauvais résultats derrière
et l'année où il a mal joué ça c'est ça
le dé par d'excellents résultats après
donc ouais bon ça reste
problème de connexion Hikaru qui a perdu
un
écran de contrôle
il y a personne qui demande à eau de
remettre sa caméra
de surveillance il y a des passes droits
hier soir il était quand même giga
correct à chaque fois qu'il y a des
problèmes de cam ou quoi on le voyait se
déplacer remettre
c'est pas le cas du carreau
ça pourrait être disqualificatoires
même la lumière
une comportement excellent
mais là c'est étonnant qu'on lui demande
pas de d'habitude il demande ouais là il
a terminé la partie normalement il
laisse pas faire ça
après la dernière fois ils ont même
laissé Hikaru naviguer sur sur son écran
pendant une partie
il fait un peu ce qu'il veut en fait
l'étonnant en tout cas
je comprends que pendant la partie sois
pas très agréable de le faire mais bon
les règles sont les règles
c'est une erreur de mon temps non c'est
moi qui règle le logiciel donc c'est pas
une erreur du monteur attention turn
chez test de pas dire de la merde quand
même
quand tu sais pas il y a
soyez un problème il y avait une
deuxième caméra elle a disparu
après je vais essayer de voir si je peux
je vois pas d'autres caméras non j'ai
vraiment l'impression que
je suis étonné qu'elle soit pas remise
en service plus rapidement
il a fait tout 4
non mais là aussi à la cam il y a pas il
y a plus la cam de sécurité du carreau
en fait
il y a deux câbles il y a une canne des
joueurs et une canne de sécurité
c'est pas la peine de me dire qu'il y a
la cam sur le stream du car oula leur
dit montre un super Cook qui gagne là
pour les Noirs oh là là
très très jolie cavalier des 4 cavalier
prend des cartes dames français 1 tours
français un dame tu en penser un match
et surtout reprends ces 7 cavalueux de
ici que ça marche pas et vous êtes
débile ou quoi évidemment que je peux te
recadrer la cam du carreau c'est juste
que normalement il doit réouvrir l'autre
d'ici deux secondes et que
et que il y a une deuxième caméra
normalement c'est pas de ça marche ou ça
marche pas ici
et ça marche encore un cahier des 4
tours français 7 qui est prend F3 roi H1
tour H4
donc on verra si la recadrera pas en
recadra comme ça mais il a plus de 4 de
sécurité
il a raté deux fois qu'il y ait des
quatre c'est quand même pas très dur
enfin c'est pas facile mais
c'était pas un trouvable
avec les Noirs je pense pas qu'il est
loupé
mais bon c'était pas si simple
là je pense que le truc c'est que sur
dames c'est deux tours C4 tu en penses 4
puis on prend ces quatre dames français
4 c'est cavalier 7 on peut
peut-être faire dam F4 quand même
et c'est égalité matérielle
mais après il a pareil il a raté
à voir
ça
c'est mieux pour les blancs
ça va refaire plus de
dans ma septame F4 G3 il y a pas de
match 5
dommage 5 c'est terrible
dans ma seat il a encore d'amour
c'est pas loin d'être foutu le pion est
tellement proche de dames pour ikaro
il peut faire un échec de échec
il va revenir en B2
et revenir en B4 ouais il a de nouveau
la case H4
il récupère un peu de temps mais bon
c'est pas simple
tellement dur de savoir où tu dois
mettre ton roi avec les noirs
c'est juste tellement dur de savoir où
tu dois [ __ ] de ton roi
normalement c'est sûr que tu finis par
perdre ces trucs là
ok récupère un punto quand même
maintenant le roi va réussir à monter
il va prendre G4
là il y a pas du B7 juste en bulant
le roi devrait pouvoir réussir à se
cacher
ces choses faites
même c'est 5 x 8 dames des 5
ouais c'est chaud je sais pas si il va
la tenir
ah bizarre d'avoir mis cet échec inutile
le roi va se cacher là
ou pas ouais c'est dur à dire
c'est extrêmement difficile à dire
ça y est il s'est caché
cette fois-ci c'est caché
et la CB8 dame
et c'est terrible
il était pas loin il était pas loin
de s'en sortir
là il y a trop de dames
c'est victoire du carreaux est-ce qu'il
va rebrancher ouais voilà et voilà la
deuxième camer rebranchée après la
partie simplement
étonnant
étonnant arbitrage
ouais mais pas assez fort
les caméras qui est revenu ouais
non étonnant parce que
généralement il me demande
après je vais dire ça change pas grand
chose de toute façon
c'est vraiment là juste pour
pour décorer quoi ça a pas grand grand
impact mais
c'est plus cosmétique qu'autre chose
mais bon
là du coup donc c'est la dernière partie
de 5 + 1 on s'en est on est dans le
mauvais sens carreau elle est noir
pardon
encore de la partie d'avant
qui était un sacré spectacle mais avec
Caro qui est simplement plus fort que
son adversaire
je sais pas si elle non je pense pas
pressez vraiment des grosses pattes mais
ça doit pas le gêner
outre mesure
tu veux expliquer le 5 + 1 c'est une
cadence 5 minutes pour le 2 pour jouer
la partie et une seconde par coup de
bonus
mais il est pas si bien car une nouvelle
fois son sonde se fait attaquer il a pas
la colonne C
c'est le fou qui va s'ouvrir ouais
il reste trois meilleurs remplis ouais
alors après il manquait quand même à
l'irrézard dans la compétition qui est
numéro un mondiale en blitz
mais oui qu'il pouvait pas y être à
il jouait pas donc
je sais pas assez d'argent bêtement
peut-être ça le fait chier
peut-être que ça le fait juste chier
dame BF3 c'est bien joué il veut faire
B3 pour Tours C7
focus sur de compétition je sais pas il
y a pas trop de compétition en ce moment
mais tu sais
je sais pas comment dire mais tu vois
que tu es gagné le speech ou pas en fait
tu vois c'est pas un objectif majeur de
carrière quoi enfin tu t'en fous en fait
donc
après c'est bizarre parce qu'il est pas
inscrit au championnat du monde de Blitz
c'est rapide non plus
donc il va jouer tu reprends à cette
fois il est gagnant en fait
Sarine la partie c'est déroule un peu
toute seule
après il faut la conclure
il faut qu'il pousse ces Punto quand
même
à 5 à 6
pour C3 il sécurise sur D4 il veut
tourner 3
et qui a étranger trois pions plongés 3
tours B8 ouais ça doit passer
c'est quand les candidats voilà ce sera
pas avant 2024 là il va y avoir la phase
de qualification candidat
un coup là les parties auront un grand
enjeu
la difficulté là pour Ikao c'est que le
cavalier F5 est mal placé pour déloger
la tour des trois
mais le fou bien joué NiAl qui va
repartir en D2
et qui va permettre de pousser les doses
pour une torche
c'est le match qui c'est le tournoi qui
décide
des qualifier
du qualifié pour le match championnat du
monde
grosse interrogation sur les prochains
candidats c'est ce que Magnus va tenter
de se qualifier alors il serait
qualifier à haut et l'eau
ou pas
canya
un début de match un peu difficile qui
revient et qui est même pas vraiment
dominé tant que ça
peut-être si Carouge ou un peu en troll
pour pour faire le show
le chaud dans le sens le malin
et mettre la pression à
[Musique]
mais
on peut pas dire que
Ikaru dominent réellement ce match pour
le moment
donc là on voit que les 1h30 sont
passées
et il y aura une heure de trois plus un
ça se compte dans millions ou centaines
de milliers la win en dizaine de
milliers
mais Ikao qui est un peu plus fort que
NiAl mais
il nous a un peu à l'esbruf en début de
match en
en étant en mode un peu trop leur en
mode joue des ouvertures un peu à
l'arrache nanani nanana nage domine et
en fait
il est plus fort mais c'est pas
c'est pas fou quoi
plus simple attention là maintenant il
menace pour prendre des deux et là il y
a tout reprend B5 il s'est fait arnaquer
ça farine
arnaque
c'est la force du carreau sarnak arnaque
sévère
pas de bolus
même si c'est pas énorme ouais c'était
l'écart de Maximilien
entre un point et deux points et cabine
grosse diff en fait
quand les niveaux sont circées
parce qu'il y a ce pion encore qui est
fort
ok va voir ce qui fait tourner c'est pas
encore nul
c'est encore évidemment un gros avantage
et il va mettre le fond c'est 7 essayer
d'avancer le pion peut-être
et peut-être il va tenter de faire un
truc comme ça
donc il y a du mal à s'approcher
mettre le rang F1 cavalier 3
il menace rien il lui manque un punto
pour venir s'installer à sort le
cavalier
il va falloir réussir à passer le pur en
B7
je sais pas ce qu'il veut il veut
ramener le cavalier E6
c'est bien joué là ce que fait Niall il
interdit la colonne C
garou qui a plus trop de temps
il passe aussi sous les 20 secondes ça
peut être déterminant
4 c'est pas mal joué ce qui va faire
cavalier prend F4 essayer de jouer la
finale non
du coup F5
il va tenter un tour à 5 tours à 7 B7 B8
chasse la tour une fois
deux fois
seulement deux fois et peut-être il va
décaler sa tour maintenant attention
niale
attendez trois tours B3
ça y est les carreau qui a plus trop de
temps mais réussi à ramener son roi oh
c'est terrible
il va pas la gagner NiAl ah il est
dégoûté
il aurait fallu qu'il ait la même
position avec
son pion encore en vie
et c'est raté
ouais c'est vraiment
du bolus
mais il défend bien Ikao
en fait pour gagner il fallait
simplement monter le roi
jusqu'en c'est si c'est poussé
c'était aussi simple que ça
mais il a craqué
terrible
terrible pour
il va y avoir maintenant 5 minutes de 10
minutes de pause important les pauses
il se fait trois arnaquer
c'est ça le problème c'est qu'il se fait
beaucoup trop arnaquer
et c'est ça qui fait que carreau est
devant mais bon c'est son gros point
fort d'arnaquer elle est partie
il s'est trop fait arnaquer
c'est terrible
hier j'ai regardé le replay de la
pick-up j'ai forcément apprécié sympa ce
que tu fais pour ta commune merci à toi
ça révise ouais
je sais pas après peut-être qu'il
regarde
ce qui s'est passé dans les parties je
sais pas ce qui regarde
j'en ai j'en ai aucune idée
en tout cas il joue à il joue pas mal il
fait son match
on peut pas dire qu'il fasse un mauvais
match
NiAl
ça c'est le stream en italien
je suis en train de regarder
ça m'a fait sursauter
c'est de voir le stream en anglais
ils sont tous barrés
c'est demain la fine demi-finale avec
Maxime
c'est demain
là c'est une heure de trois plus un
la il reste encore une heure du coup de
trois plus un et une demi-heure de
belette
et après ce sera terminé
on aura le match demain et encore la
finale pas de match pour la troisième
place ce sera la fin de cette année de
speechs ça reprendra l'an prochain
qui est favori en cas de carreaux Magnus
un Magnus
un terme de calcul qui devance l'autre
mvl Magnus et Hikaru sûrement Hikaru
quand même
quel jour la finale je crois qu'on sait
pas il voulait la mettre dimanche je
crois de base
mais je pense que c'est après ça a été
annoncé mardi mais ça peut recharger
au final melikaru elle me valait carou
c'est Hikaru
c'est plutôt Magnus mais pas de beaucoup
ouais ça va repartir on a hâte
on a bien hâte
de la différence entre un bel et Naka un
truc c'est que ouais belle généralement
il gagne on tactifiant tous ses
adversaires sauf que là c'est l'inverse
avec Hikaru
fait mieux que Maxime ce que Maxime fait
très bien
donc il le gène dans son propre style en
fait
allez ça repart
maintenant c'est du 3 + 1
il faut pas que ça de problème de
connexion
voilà la position
c'est un gambidame refusait où il joue
avec E3 donc il garde le fou c'est un
bloqué
3 plus simple c'est une belle cadence
c'est souvent là que le match finit par
se décider il s'est un peu décanté en 5
+ 1
on stream non non après je streamerai
pas
une position intéressante Icaro qui a
repris de G pour s'ouvrir la colonne G
qui joue avec B3 à fou B2 pour jouer le
nom de la grande diagonale
et aussi le pion isolé en dessin
clair c'est position en toujours pareil
d'un côté il y a trois affaibli mais ce
qu'il est vraiment faible
et puis à spion isolé il va pouvoir
faire F4 contrôle des cases mettre le
fond F3
je pense qu'il va faire F4
non il fait fout des trois c'est bien
joué il veut mettre le fond F5
car on peut faire l'écart là il mène
déjà deux points donc si ça se démarre
mal pour Sarine et qui l'ont perdent de
3 le match est tout de suite plié
donc on va voir si réussi à installer ce
fond F5 ou pas
j'ai l'impression que ça commence à être
bien pour les blancs les noirs arrivent
vraiment pas à toucher le roi cavalier
H4 H2 dame D6 F4 on touche pas les
diagonales ici
on touche pas le roi en réalité
c'est 8h c'est un surfoi F5 avec
cavalier H4 encore échec c'est pour ça
que je le signalé mais
là il échange petit à petit les pièces
il va avoir un petit avantage
il prend il va rentrer dans cette finale
qui doit être nul mais c'est un tout
petit peu pénible à jouer pour les noirs
sur tout qui peut y avoir un jour du
faux F5 Foussais 8 pour aller taper les
pions de l'autre côté l'avantage au
temps
et surtout si Carola gagne il va faire
mal plus trois après on rentre dans des
territoires un peu complexes pour
remonter
parce que plus 4 + 5 ça risque d'être
déjà vraiment terminé
donc Niall Sarine de nouveau sous
pression avec moins de temps
car un peu accéléré la cadence
elle est solides à Rouen
il est extrêmement solide
mais il commence à jouer vite à jouer
précis
et mettre petite pression à toutes les
parties
réussir un placer son roi quand même
avec les Noirs il a
il a pas mal défendu
c'est peut-être même lui qui peut être
mieux la Hikaru qui a perdu beaucoup de
tempo
ce roi là qui en déçu alors que le roi
blanc n'est qu'arrivé qu'en E1
donc attention
il s'est placé
contrôle les cases
supposition doit être nulle mais bon
avec l'avantage au temps et car oui va
la joindre un petit peu je pense il peut
quand même beaucoup de pions sur blanc
mais le fou il y a pas accès
qui va faire le tour avec son cheval
essayer de jouer sur le CASE avec le
cavalier
on met le cavalier a réussi pas vraiment
à toucher les Punto par derrière
mais problème de connexion pour NiAl il
a plus qu'une barre
carreaux qui fait semblant de réfléchir
à ma réalité il cherche que à faire
tomber là
il veut juste profiter de la connexion
il va tenter quelque chose
ça va pas suffire
OK puis on prend un quatre prises
vraiment jouer la cour en fait
qui est fixe quand même un punto là-bas
il peut tenter cavalier 6 encore mais
c'est risqué
il fera pas mieux que nul les carreaux
il aura pas réussi à faire parler
davantage de connexion
et cavaliers
à certains moments
on le voit et oui Caro qui joue là
dessus
c'est beau les échecs quand c'est jouer
comme ça on utilise toutes les armes
et un peu comme hier
les conditions de saut était vraiment
très très mauvaise mais les conditions
encore aujourd'hui
qui favorisent un joueur assez nettement
et dans les deux cas c'est le joueur le
plus fort
OK
bon ça échange il y a le fou contre le
cavalier mais là la position du carreau
semble correcte
il a une position il était un peu moins
bien qui se ressemblait mais il y avait
une paire de cavaliers en plus
OK
il va repaire B2 à la fin c'est ça
l'idée
c'est que si prends-toi en C5 il y a B2
qui tombe
bien joué de la part du carreaux
trouver extrêmement vite
il a peut-être pas mieux anial
c'est toute la difficulté à un
contre-ikaro
de réussir à jouer vite et bien
à la fin et ouais et le problème c'est
que ça menace dame bermat mais aussi
dame B1 échec est prise
et sur dame C2 il a peut-être
tourcé1 et me prendre des trois
ça doit quand même être
proche d'égalité mais c'est un peu
chiant c'est un pion de moi pour le
moment
sûrement mettre la dame en F4 mais il y
a que les Noirs qui jouent pour le gain
il veut quoi il veut tourber 8 on
reprend F7 on reprend F7 dame C7
j'imagine
et Kawa peut-être un piège de marlou là
dedans
ok il a pas fait étonnant mais il devait
y avoir un truc j'arrivais pas à le
trouver
c'est pour tenir la case 4
taf 5
d'un point à 6 probablement tour B2 ou
dame 4
mais là c'est une 48 contre 26 secondes
allez c'est peut-être le moment du plus
C2 c'est quand même un vrai punto de
moins un roi H7 c'est bien joué
et tourbé 6 il va faire H5 G6 sûrement
j'ai 5 intéressants aussi
d'autant plus même
il a jamais avoir d'âme prend à 6 à
cause de dame 4 il rentre dans cette
finale
qui a l'air d'être très chiante un tour
à 4 tu dois vouloir tomber 4 tu reprends
G4 et jouer avec
les pions
ok c'est bien défendu de la part de
farine quand même
mais si personne là ça va être dur il a
de nouveau un petit problème de
connexion
des
3 G6
là il est déco ouais c'est terrible
c'est terrible
sa connexion qui tient de moins en moins
après ça se joue pas la connexion non
plus en ce match et Caro est plus fort
mais ça hypothèque le semblant de chance
qui reste il a perdu deux fois quatre ou
cinq secondes dans cette partie
c'est dur
ent
et ça ça gagne tout seul
et ça y est les carrés fait plus trois
points
internet qui marche de moins en moins
bien côté indien comme un symbole
élastique à roue la gagne
ça fera plus 4 à partir de plus simple
le match est vraiment 100% plié
mais là encore c'est pas ouais problème
de connexion quota indien une nouvelle
fois
il venait de gagner au noir en plus donc
c'était pas la bonne couleur
ouais ça suit complètement
non il a pas perdu à cause sa connexion
Gaius il est il est en dessous je pense
que ça a pas changé grand chose au score
en réalité
c'est juste que ça hypothèque vraiment
tout retour possible
mettre la cam je crois qu'avec certains
pays zoom en fait le logiciel qui est
utilisé créé des problèmes je sais
qu'avec les joueurs chinois c'est c'est
spécifiquement le
programme qui fait qui fait bugger
donc là en mettant deux câbles sur zoom
et tout peut-être que 6 ans en internet
un peu à limite
mais là sur le match je crois que ça
change rien parce que il a eu allez
peut-être 7 8 problèmes de 4 secondes
dans le match c'est pas ça qui a changé
le truc
salut Phoenix
je regarde la vidéo de ne pas essayer
dingue il est littéralement avoir tenté
c'est rentrer ce coup dans un engine
c'est de la pure et simple triche je
pensais que le mec du chat exagéré non
non mais d'après moi on m'a dit aussi
ouais
ouais mais il y a personne qui fera rien
je te rassure
quand tu es au top tu fais ce que tu
veux en fait il y a personne qui fait
rien
de problème dans une heure de son match
contre guéri on a commencé 15 minutes en
retard à cause de ça terrible
ouais
c'est comme ça qu'est-ce que tu veux
mais pourquoi en fait ça commence en
retard ça se trouve que j'arrive jamais
à comprendre en fait
tu as des problèmes ça te regarde enfin
je comprends pas pourquoi les matchs
sont décalés
tu as des problèmes d'ordies des
problèmes tu perds parfois et puis c'est
pas grave
fait partie du jeu
il faut des règles quand même un peu
solides
voilà de façon le match il est plié à
dos et c'est pas ça qui changeait grand
chose
là ça change rien du tout bon là c'est
fou c'est ça et ça abandon allez hop ça
dégage Hikaru
ça fait plus 4
ouais ça y est il a lâché mentalement
il a lâché mentalement un peu comme ça
hier quand il a perdu les deux parties
là en belette comme Caro Anna comme tous
ça y est il a fini par lâcher
le mental qui ne suit pas à côté indien
mais difficile quand on est autant sous
pression mener au score
d'ailleurs tu disais tu voulais pas
jouer contre son compte twitch
secondaire mais un de ces mails a été
fermé l'autre il y a plus de partie
dessus j'avais dit qu'il avait un style
ressemblant à Hans Nima aussi je sais
pas si tu te rappelles chicorne
tu as dit que sa manière de jouer
ressemble un peu à Hans
ça ressemblait vraiment en fait
c'est premier degré en fait
mais après du coup je sais pas sur
quelle partie on ne sa triché ou pas
mais ça il ressemble quoi
c'était le même style de jeu
après ça va
tu peux pas savoir en fait
complexe mais oui oui c'est vraiment
en skit bah je sais pas moi les parties
que j'ai joué contre lui avec le style
qu'il avait je sais pas si tu t'es ou
pas en fait parce que tu t'es pas sur
toutes ces parties donc je peux pas
savoir
mais ce qui est sûr c'est que chasse
bragnat il avait un style
qui ressemble mais il y en a beaucoup
qui ont un style qui ressemble à un
fait de voir je vais check parce que la
partie bon elle a pas dans elle a pas
d'intérêt honnêtement ouais d'ailleurs
il abandonne ça y est match terminé
mais il a vraiment eu ses comptes bloqué
mais je sais qu'en ce moment il y a un
gros ménage qui est fait sur chaise
comme vraiment
une bonne heure de plus ah non c'est
encore deux heures Maxime oh attention
quand même elle chess il faut être
sérieux
mais oui le style ressemblait et je l'ai
dit plein de fois c'était bizarre très
mauvais ce stratégiquement et tout d'un
coup le mec te défonce tactiquement
c'est exactement comme Hans
et même résultat
c'est terrible quand même
une heure et demie avec les pauses oui
mais ce qui est beau c'est qu'il y a
encore des problèmes de co-maxime
aujourd'hui là pour nia il y en a pas
mal en réalité
ce serait beau que ton match se joue à
la coke quand même demain
ça fait plaisir
ça fait toujours plaisir quand ça se
joue à la connexion
j'espère que tu seras bien connecté
demain
coupure de courant à Paris demain on
réclame rat ta défaite si t'as plus de
connexion quand même Maxime tu nous
connais on est des vrais enflures avec
la
co mais bon moi j'ai demandé aussi
forfait sur une partie du carreau
aujourd'hui il y avait pas la deuxième
caméra allumée elle s'est éteinte tout
d'un coup
le Maxime en finale comme les Bleus bon
je vais surtout Maxime champion du monde
de rapides ou de Blitz j'ai envie de te
dire
c'est là qu'on veut le voir à notre
Maxime c'est là qu'on va vibrer demain
on va kiffer quand même mais il faut
quand même avoir les objectifs
principaux en tête
c'est dans pas si longtemps que ça c'est
dans 10 jours au Kazakhstan championnat
du monde de rapides c'est là qu'on
voudra que notre requin français soit
200%
. Carouge ou très bien je trouve
aujourd'hui
ouais non Maxime c'est
demain c'est un match de gala sympa mais
c'est
c'est le titre de champion du monde on
espère qu'il le défende qu'il y arrive
ça sera difficile c'est très difficile
même
mais impossible n'est pas français
on le voit tous les jours en ce mois de
novembre décembre
on espère que
qui réussissent à faire une grosse
performance du côté du Kazakhstan
je sais plus c'est 15 + 10 ou 25 + 10 il
y a tellement de cadence différentes
très dommage qui Carole covid au Kazakhs
ça ce serait vraiment pas de bol il
avait fini combien déjà un championnat
du monde de Blitz si Carlos 100 125e ou
un truc comme ça non
125e joueur mondial
150e
il n'y a plus de testovid oui mais bon
même sans test il peut quand même avoir
un covid
ça serait pas de bol
ce serait pas de bol
je pense qu'il car aussi c'est son
objectif principal
de la fin de saison championnat du monde
de Blitz il y aura Magnus aussi
voilà est-ce qu'il réussit encore à
mettre un punto
c'est ça qui menace maths il va faire
tout aussi
ou pas encore je crois qu'il est pas
inscrit du tout non c'est à dire qu'il
joue pas les raisins probablement je
sais pas je l'ai pas vu mais après je
checke pas tous les jours et je sais pas
si la liste est fermée
il va faire quoi à faire 3 et 3 à 8
le 22 s'il joue
allez dernière minute
mais bizarre ne pas jouer non pour aller
Raisa juste ça fait aucun sens
enfin c'est quand même un bouton noir
quoi
et de toute façon les les qualificatifs
pour les prochains candidats ils sont
pas du tout annoncés encore
tu veux tout reprendre 5 donc c'est pour
ça que il va probablement y avoir d'un
F4
donc
intéressant la partie là si Caro la
défend
un shot pour ruine ouais mais bon
c'est pas fait
cavalier 6 va bien tout défendre
mais il va l'amener si cela d'ailleurs
il tape 5 il tape à deux aussi
et des trois H4 tour A4 qu'est-ce que
c'est bien joué à 4
qui fait mal ton point F4 à
oh mais il va peut-être se faire mater
quand même
tout rêve 5
dames des 4
ça me Troie et là il a un problème
IKO
3D 3 tu reprends aussi
il va peut-être avoir un problème de
Punto en F7 il y a trop de Punto
puis on prend
tu reprends aussi si tu en prends aussi
Safet
pour C1 tours 5
tourbé 1 et surtout F5 avait tour B8 7
ou 8 F8 dames
qui revient un peu
il y a plus rien à [ __ ] qu'il a gagné
cette année peut-être
peut-être peut-être mais attention quand
même
à la déclaration d'impôts 2022 qui va
arriver en 2023
qui peut faire mal quand même qui peut
faire très mal
peut-être un manque d'expérience côté
avoir gagné beaucoup
il a oublié les frères qui rap tout
qui vont quand même vite venir remettre
de l'ordre dans tout ça
et qui vont faire ça les raisins à jouer
plus de tournois
en fait c'est l'état français qui a
gagné beaucoup bah ouais en fait c'est
la martingale il vient vivre en France
vraiment très bien pour le développement
tu vas être dans les meilleures
conditions pour bien jouer oui bon en
fait on va taper tout ton fric frérot
ah bah oui c'est ça qui est beau tu
penses que tu viens en France et que
ouais mais en fait
on est quand même là à la sortie
il doit pas être bien il va pas être
bien à mon avis en 2000 en 2023 en
septembre 2023 il va avoir un petit coup
de blues
ça va suer quand tu as les raisins
qui fait B5
au final il aura pas gagné plus que
parram oui il va pas être bien il va pas
être bien
il doit être bien apparemment en réalité
quand il voit ça
en tant que tout bénef effectivement de
nationaliser un jeune dans la formation
est terminée et oui
bien sûr
c'est tout le principe globalement
de l'immigration mais bon peu importe
tu payes pas l'éducation des gens ils
viennent
il y a déjà tout qui est payé et tu
ramasses le bénef quoi
pratique
pratique pratique
voilà c'est vrai qu'on a fait un très
gros coup
si bien le champion du monde on va se
mettre très très bien
les grands maîtres indiens qui viennent
ouais on peut se mettre très bien
pour 7
Nico qui est pas super bien mais ça
nialshine depuis tout à l'heure il fait
pas un mauvais match mais juste icaru il
réussit à tout défendre et à un moment
donné il a un peu accéléré il a fait mal
sur quelques game
mais là il remet la pression au temps S
et c'est dommage qu'il y a eu ce petit
flottement là pour NiAl
après il est aussi là à cause de la
pression mise par
par les quatre Rica
un aujourd'hui
il va sûrement mettre une tour en C8 un
cavalier en F4
ouais comme ça aussi et cavalier F4
menace cavalier des trois au passage
grosse partie du carreau
mais grosse partie de farine pardon face
à eikao qui suit
et il aura pas sombre et je voyais
sombrer et puis non en fait
il est solide
j'ai 6 qui est rangé Skype
allez faut encore gagner celle là et
revenir un peu
il est vraiment dangereux ça rime en
tout cas en match
il est sérieux et solide
c'est 5 en fait pour revenir vers le
pion
c'est peut-être un peu raté
il a peut-être laissé signal se replacer
peut-être ici carreau pardon je me
trompe de prénom dans dans cette partie
il remet ses pièces la menace qui est 5
ça c'est qu'il arrive jamais à passer il
obtient des avantages stratégiques des
meilleurs positions mais ça suffit
jamais
et là il réfléchit trop une nouvelle
fois
il échange les Punto
il a toujours une bonne position
mais il lui reste plus que 10 secondes
ça risque de pas être assez contre un ni
carou déchaîné cavalier 2 ou c'est si ça
peut être c'est 6 qui est intéressant
mais il a le temps de prendre et j'ai
trois tours D1 donc il se place derrière
le pion qui est des trois pour qu'il
prend ses 5
cavalier aussi insupportable
aussi c'est bien joué
il va mettre la tour en C2 cavalier
prend C5 ils peuvent peut-être faire 4
même en premier
la tour en A5 et ça ça doit gagner quand
même
ouais c'est pas si sûr que ça gagne en
fait la Tour Blanche est bien placée
et ça a pas l'air simple
il monte pas le droit encore il veut
contourner de l'autre côté
par vers 7 D6 il va faire tourner 5
échecs
de F4 et roi B4 mais
ça doit être nul ce truc là je vois pas
comment il progresse en fait Tour Eiffel
il va forcer F4
ou 4 mais le roi va pouvoir rentrer dans
le trou et en plus il décale et il prend
le pion de l'autre côté
ouais et là le pion h va faire mal
c'est difficile d'avancer encore qu'il y
arrive un roi prend il va réussir à
faire F4
à aimer le pion le pion h va trop vite
c'est terrible
ouais c'est terrible il a gardé ses
pions h sur l'échiquier c'est c'est ce
qui lui coûte
à la fin
il va lui manquer un thème pas il peut
pas il peut pas arrêter le pion
il lui manque le tempo
qui souffle
et qui fait tourner le maximum le
chronomètre
et c'est la pause
il n'y a qui rate encore une victoire
mais ouais ouais il en aura raté trois
quatre un des comme ça
bien joué en tout cas de la part de
qui tient
qui tient qui tient qui tient qui tient
et qui finit
souvent par tirer des demi points
après bravo quand même Annie qui donne
pas de points entier
ça c'est quand même très positif
mais il réussit à systématiquement
à se sortir des griffes de NiAl
et qui garde trois points d'écart ouais
trois points c'est que c'est quand même
large parce qu'il y a pas tant de
victoire que ça
trois points c'est vraiment beaucoup
surtout avec les petits problèmes de
connexion en belette
qui risque de lui coûter cher
mais il récupère à jamais trois points
belette faute qui reviennent à deux ou à
un point on l'a vu hier avec Wesley même
sur monde en fait quand tu es derrière
après ton père une et
c'était trop
puis bon il a pas la nana
complexe
qui fait la différence
génial ouais un peu en dessous on
comprend pourquoi il est arrivé en 2000
il est pas il est loin d'être ridicule
on n'avait pas senti non plus il carou
si large contre aronia mais on s'en
Sarine encore un peu plus fort
il est pas il est pas il est pas
ridicule
jusqu'à 15 minutes
mais il
suprême de CO quand même font qui sera
en dessous à minima
ça devrait être une pause plus courte
surtout qui reste que 22 minutes de bus
derrière
qui est déjà revenu
maintenant il est très bon en belette
aussi mais oui s'il a des problèmes de
connexion c'est une autre histoire
après c'est la bête E4 en face ouais
allez let's go
il faut que ça reprenne là il y en a
marre il y en a marre d'attendre
4h c'est quand même long mais en plus là
les pauses de manière complètement
inopinée pour 22 minutes de jeu c'est
trop allez let's go
si on veut faire si à star on fait
Siesta
allez let's go
même les joueurs en ont marre bah ouais
mais bon
c'est quand même relativement long quoi
c'est quand même très long quand même
format ouais ils ont pas fait le truc le
plus court de l'histoire des échecs quoi
c'est vrai que mettre un tout petit peu
moins de pause ça ferait plaisir
voilà sans les deux poses de millions on
aurait déjà fini la cadence 3 plus 1 en
fait quand on y pense
pour aider les gens enchaîner
pas forcément besoin de
allez ça repart
surtout au début là derrière ça plombe
après il y aura encore une pause avant
le Bullet ouais
alors naï ignal qui va envoyer un genre
de catalan
ça serait bien qu'il revienne à deux
points voir même à un point au début des
belettes il y a 5 points d'écart je vous
disais que c'était terminé
à 3 4 points c'est quasi terminé un ou
deux points on peut avoir une petite
vibration suivante
on va voir si réussi à mettre un peu de
pression ici
[Musique]
j'aime bien les blancs quand même ce
pion F6 il est un peu bizarre
il bloque bien tout même
fixe il fixe l'aile dame c'est plutôt
bien joué il fixe le pion en C6
maintenant il va tenter tête de jouer 3
de stabiliser doubler la colle sur la
colonne c'est une nouvelle fois il a
l'avantage NiAl mais depuis tout à
l'heure
il a réussi pas forcément à conclure
mais il y a aucun excellent défenseur
ici 1099 sur 100 comme note
OK
propose les changes cavaliers prend
évidemment
voici ce prix il va jouer E3 ici
j'imagine
pour stabiliser en fait l'option il est
bien en E3 parce que moi il est plus une
cible et
protège le pion des 4 c'est pour ça tout
à l'heure que j'ai l'impression qu'il va
faire 3
ça paraît quand même ultra logique de
mettre le pion E3
il prend beaucoup de temps pour pour
faire ces décisions il lui reste plus
qu'une 35
elle a tout reprend C4 évidemment et
dames prends
et aller baisser
6 allez là vraiment une belle position
ici il y a
la racaille qui dégage peut-être
côté américain
ça c'est vraiment dur à jouer au noir
parce qu'il a quoi il a deux pions pour
la cale mais ils sont vraiment très
forts c'est Punto
après il va falloir quand même réussir à
avancer
c'est pas gagné encore mais ça avantage
je sais pas si il doit faire cavalier à
6 ou pas non il le fait pas
le fou G2 qui tient tellement bien le
pion c'est 6
à 4 il fixe tour B1 il va aller il va
aller taper le pion
il va y avoir tourbé 8
et il faut réussir à faire des seins que
4 F4 5 s'il y arrive c'est gagné
il reviendra de Punto
petite sueur côté carreaux
qui met vraiment qui fait vraiment son
match on le voit il quand il tombe à -4
là qu'il a donné une game je pensais
qu'il allait complètement lâcher
finalement il réussit à revenir quand
même il est du roman
besogneux
pour et même peut-être dire rudoyant
ouais je sais pas c'est peut-être
rudoyant l'objectif l'adjectif
pas qu'elle adjectif vous vous emploie
c'est encore plus beau
il est sur les cases là
même des quatre dame 5 encore dame de
bien jouer
tout changer 4
et là il va le prendre le pion G4
ça lui libère le pion F1 c'est surtout
ça le problème pour Yarou c'est pour ça
qu'il joue P5
il échange une fois en B5
c'est tout ça là tout ça la force du
carreaux là c'est de défendre ses
positions indéfendables
et touche la dame encore
ce qui va lui caler un F4 entre ton nom
il va sûrement mettre
en train de se faire arnaquer
ah c'est terrible
tellement dur de gagner une partie
contre Ricardo
il va peut-être faire cavalier Descartes
cavalué un
B8 et cavaliers
ah c'est terrible
c'est terrible il passe de gagnant à
Adam de moi
alors c'est pas terminé encore
mais presque en réalité
et c'est cette partie qui va le clôturer
parce qu'il menace pas des 6 à cause de
dames C4 échecs
ou pas
peut-être qu'il aurait encore eu 5
ou bien jouer sur apprendre 6 ah non
attends il y a pas foi je crois il y a
C8 dame français 8 fois H3 fou français
dame prend aussi
5 seul coup
si on prend il va peut-être faire fouter
7 ici non
faut jouer
ah mais Adam G6
il se fait clôturer la tronche signale
il était complètement gagnant il pouvait
revenir à plus d'eux il est repasse à -
il se fait clôturer la gueule terrible
ouais c'est ce qu'on appelle se faire
clôturer la tronche c'est terrible
on va voir si réussi une nouvelle fois à
rester dedans
il y aura tout dessin que tout B7 ouais
je sais pas ce qui rate mais sûrement
fou des cinq et tu es meilleur
qui défend nettement trop bien pour NiAl
c'est la difficulté des longs matchs
contre ikaro c'est d'ailleurs une des
raisons pour lesquelles le speech joue
dans ce format c'est que ça favorise
vraiment un énorme
très très difficile à jouer
et une nouvelle fois
il s'est montré plus fort
terrible
qui est vraiment un pitoyable
allez elle avait une petite chance après
hikao est probablement quand même gagné
le match même en perdant cette partie là
une certaine marge mais
elle montre bien
toute la difficulté
du travail à fournir pour pour
l'emporter
c'était gros avantage et il s'est fait
magouiller au pire moment
il a pas forcément pris la bonne
direction anale
ranial en fait il joue bien c'est juste
que ça se
ça se joue à pas grand chose
mais c'est pas grand chose il est il est
énorme en réalité
c'est que c'est pas sûr qu'il puisse
combler les cartes de niveau même en
travaillant des millions d'heures mais
mais il a fait son match c'est sûr
on voit les carreau encore en dans le
dur je pense que sur dame prend B5 à
foutrant H3
qui continue à faire des bonnes parties
carreaux qui continuent à avoir du mal
mais Caro qui continue à défendre
du coup il a c'était une gaffe en B5
mais si vous remarquez il a il Caro il a
pas fait d'énormes gaffes en fait il
fait jamais des normes gaffes quasiment
mais ça il domine pas ouais il défend
juste mieux il prend les points quand il
faut
mais dans les parties les dominent pas
en fait juste si il perd jamais
ça hyper jamais je rigole jamais de
points faciles jamais jamais jamais
jamais jamais jamais jamais jamais
jamais jamais
et non seulement il défend mais en plus
quand il défend il contre
c'est qu'il te vole pas que des
demi-points il vole une fois de temps en
temps un point entier
et au bout d'un moment ça épuise tout
bêtement
il épuise ses adversaires
qui finissent par exploser en fait
alors là il explose même pas vraiment en
fait il explose sur une deux parties de
temps en temps mais ça suffit
c'est difficile il est vraiment
difficile à jouer
peut-être un cahier
ca va aller prendre un Melun et on peut
prendre B1 ou revenir en E5 et prendre
peut-être ici l'un ou l'autre
génial qui se remet mal au temps parce
qu'il revérifie tu recalcules ouais
c'est
là il est vraiment rentré
dans sa tête
et même s'il gagne en fait il doit faire
tellement d'efforts
s'il était revenu à deux points ce
serait pas la même tu as une balle pour
revenir à un point là il te reste encore
trois points derrière
tu es loin quoi
on peut dire que Niall s'était pas 0% de
chance de gagner ce match c'était
il est loin d'être favori dans tout le
match mais c'était pas à 0% comme comme
carruana contre
Magnus on voit qu'ils pose de réels
problèmes
si ça neuve joli score
s'il avait gagné l'autre où il était
gagnant là juste avant qu'il a fini par
perdre il s'est ce serait ce serait 7 8
un score
on peut pas dire qu'au fil du match le
le la différence de niveau est augmentée
et on peut pas dire que malgré les
éléments contraires ni à le Sarine et
baissé pavillon c'est pas du tout le cas
il a continué à jouer son jeu il a
continué à attaquer
il a continué à bien jouer
maintenant ça suffira peut-être pas mais
mais en tout cas il réalise un match
quasi parfait NiAl je crois qu'il y a
juste deux parties en fait qui doit
gagner et qui perd et qui font les cars
mais je trouve vicaro un tout petit peu
moins fort que dans un moment
je le trouve vraiment un tout petit peu
en dessous de
ce qu'il a eu fait peut-être l'an
dernier il y a deux ans
un tout petit peu moins précis un tout
petit peu moins
régulier on va dire
parce que c'est vrai qu'il Caro nous a
souvent
habitué à une régularité sans commune
mesure
en jouant quasiment toujours à son
niveau max tout au long des des
compétitions et c'est vrai que là il a
quelques petites bases de régime qui
sont habituellement normal j'ai tous les
autres joueurs mais qui sont pas normal
chez ikaro
et là il y a peut-être du cavalier prime
qui peut partir
à mon avis il faut qu'il se fasse
plaisir NiAl
et qui claque il claque en E6 allez
c'est bien ça claque et on voit Hikaru
là qui prend cher
l'échiquier de l'autre côté d'ailleurs
j'ai oublié de le tourner pour cette
partie
désolé les amis mais on voit
Hikaru là qui est pas bien
maintenant ça va être pour prendre des 5
faut prendre à me 8 allez NiAl
là c'est peut-être dame G4 le coup
cavalier c'est 5 peut-être qu'on peut
prendre ces 5 et prendre aussi
mais on a un yalla qui qui est en train
un peu faire les cartes c'est tatie
carreau qui craque physiquement
peut-être qu'il peut même faire foutrant
à huit dame prend à 8 tours français 5
prix c'est 5 et prises aussi
NiAl qui se concentre il veut pas la
rater celle-là
ça peut ça ça peut encore le faire
génial qui prend à 8 exactement puis
c'est 5 oh ça va lui remettre du baume
au coeur incroyable je pensais quand il
avait perdu cette partie là
si on garde la même dynamique ça
pourrait se payer cher et il pourra
regretter les quand même multiples
problèmes de connexion qu'il a eu NiAl
dans le match parce que si c'est serré à
9 7 ça aurait pu être 8 8 un très
franchement sans ces problèmes
techniques bon là il va juste jouer dame
F3 les échecs faciles protège le fou qui
va revenir vers des cinq après il y a
pas de Tours F6 si carou qui est en
train d'imploser là
il a l'air triste icaru prostré devant
son ordinateur il est en train de se
faire exploser face au pulse
les belettes pourraient être très
serrées là ouais il joue il joue un peu
moins bien que son adversaire en réalité
NiAl avec les pièces blanches qui fait
très mal ici
car oui
pour être aussi content de l'armoire
trash Clément sur le la coupure caméra
de son côté et qu'elle prend B3 il est
curé de sa nullité
alors le coup a l'air bien merdique mais
pourquoi peut-être à cause de fouder 5
cavaliers c'est un dam F5
et c'est joué
exploser l'Américain
cavalier des trois fous prends aussi
et c'est un abandon ayant encore une
partie en trois plus un il est en train
d'exploser le joueur américain où il est
pas bien
il va peut-être essayer d'un peu
temporiser la monte sur le rematch quand
même ah ouais joli coup d'enflure là au
métier ça fait semblant de pas avoir vu
qu'il y avait rematch qu'est-ce que
c'est malin côté Hikaru ouais ça utilise
de toutes les ficelles
oh que oui oh c'est malin là ça ouvre
d'autres fenêtres sur l'ordinateur
c'est extrêmement malin ah ouais c'est
beau c'est beau quand c'est comme ça là
ça suit plus aucune règle de rien c'est
magnifique
à l'expérience ouais comme quoi le site
lag et ça marche pas les remakes depuis
50 secondes ok oui ok oui les petits
signes de la main oh oui heureusement
que je suis par but parce que là c'est
forfait bon là pour moi c'est juste
forfait instantané mais c'est quand même
beau ça marche ouais ça utilise toutes
les ficelles
qu'est-ce que c'est malin ah ouais ça
c'est comme au foot ou au rugby avant
une mêlée le pilier qui reste par terre
pour se refaire les lacets ça fait déjà
une minute qui temporise ouais c'est
très très malin c'est très très malin
James comme qui a dû stopper le chrono
et il car où la tête dans les mains
ouais comme si ça ne fonctionnait pas
ouais c'est fort c'est fort
c'est fort c'est sportif aussi c'est
quand même magnifique comme attitude et
ça y est tout d'un coup le bouton remake
AR match à remarcher comme de par hasard
tout d'un coup il a cliqué et ça a
marché ah ouais c'est c'est au métier
et il sort l'écossaise
ah ouais c'était une
icario DiCaprio
une magnifique performance
ça casse complètement la dynamique c'est
très très très bien joué de sa part
et oui ça joue sur les limites ça joue
sur les limites de l'arbitrage et ça
c'est malin et en plus il a peut-être
même pu réviser la ligne qui va jouer
c'est doublement malin
icario DiCaprio
NiAl qui souffle qui souffle il a réussi
à faire tourner aussi 50 secondes de
match sans jouer c'est très très fort ce
qui vient de réaliser
c'est très très fort c'est malin
n'essayez pas de le faire parce que vous
serez pas arbitré pareil
mais c'est très très fort
c'est très très fort et là ça va lui
permettre de temporiser d'aller chercher
la nuit et d'aller en belette
c'est très très fort ce qui vient de
réaliser
et je vous souhaite petite variante et
ça y est il a retrouvé le sourire et oui
il sait qu'il a été malin là-dessus
ouais c'est beau
ignal qui suit un peu maintenant
il a joué cette petite variante un petit
peu
il est content lui il a été oui ah bah
oui là il est heureux il sait que c'est
encore passé tant que personne ne dit
rien c'est le genre de Richie mcco il
nous a fait sans finale de la Coupe du
monde de rugby et oui bien sûr qu'il est
de mauvais côté du rock mais si ça
siffle jamais ça siffle jamais hein
c'est malin c'est bien fait
et oui et ça met la NiAl qui a du mal
dans cette finale et qui va qui va un
petit peu subir et carreau qui a pu
prendre le temps de choisir son
ouverture
qui a été très malin
c'est la fin de la cadence
pas sûr qu'il atteigne
on se rappelle de ça nous Français cette
finale de Coupe du monde de rugby en
Nouvelle-Zélande
qui nous avait fait extrêmement mal avec
train duc qui avait raté une pénalité et
là la finale pas facile mais on voit
hein c'est cette petite temporisation là
extrêmement bien joué de la part du
joueur américain
qui lui a permis de complètement
retourner la pression alors qu'il était
en total tilt
très très bien fait de sa part il y a
rien à dire
la grande avantage qui est en prenant 30
secondes bah il était en plein tilt il
jouait mal et Sarine avait pris le
dessus dans le match et donc en
attendant il a pas attendu 30 secondes
il a attendu une minute trente voir même
deux minutes et ça lui a permis de
récupérer de son titre et de d'avoir de
nouveau la tête froide
et de refroidir farine qui était chaud
c'est comme prendre un temps mort au
basket quand tu as des joueurs qui sont
hyper chauds à trois points ils prennent
un temps mort pour essayer de les
refroidir bah là c'est ce qu'il a fait
il casse le momentum de l'adversaire il
se permet de se remettre dans 6 il
l'énerve lui et
c'est hyper bien fait hein c'est hyper
bien fait
c'est professionnel
il attend une 45 secondes max non non la
partie elle est finie rester de 50 ça
s'est tombé à 2 16 et ils ont arrêté le
chronomètre pendant au moins 30 secondes
mais de toute façon on faisait jamais
fait de Ford au niveau peut-être pour le
comprendre c'est très bien fait
c'est très très bien fait
voilà la finale est nulle il devrait la
tenir NiAl
on va voir tourbé ou non
finale un peu chiante mais nul
donc il restera 30 minutes pour le
Bullet
et Hikaru va commencer à plus d'eau plus
3 il est net favori on verra si réussi à
faire respecter son rang
ée qui avance et on sent qu'il est pas
il est pas serein dans ce match
ça devrait pas passer contre Magnus
entre Maxime peut-être mais pas sûr
mais là surtout C4 il va pouvoir faire
tourner deux et peut-être lui aller à
harceler le droit adverse
il va mettre la tour en des deux ouais
il va vouloir tout recettes tous deux
et on sent à quelle défense de NiAl
surtout reprend des quatre il veut quoi
il veut garder le pion ah ouais c'est
quand même complètement nul il fait tout
recettes quand même
il met Hikaru sous pression et Hikaru
qui devient un peu rougeâtre là
non il y a pas une petite rougeâtre côté
Carouge je le sens issue là oh il est
la pause va lui faire un bien fou
sur prendre des quatre trois
il va pas la perdre il va pas la perdre
du tout
elle est complexe encore NiAl faut qu'il
joue
il faut jouer la NiAl YouTube H4
et tout 3 ou tout F2 peut-être
par contre faut jouer la NiAl
là il faut jouer
ouais ça va juste faire nul
et on en reste là
mais c'est dodo c'est deux points
simplement cet écart
NiAl qui n'est pas loin et on a senti un
la dynamique qui a complètement tourné
heureusement cette finale là qu'il a
perdu avec sa dame enfin avec fou
cavalier avec trois pions NiAl contre la
dame elle fait du bien et carou quand
même
il va rester plus de 30 minutes de jeu
dans la cadence un plus un
et on n'est pas à l'abri d'une surprise
dans ce match finalement
de manière assez inattendue je dois dire
il retentera la pose tactique quoi il
refera une post tactique en cas de
besoin évidemment
ça c'est sûr
il y aura pas de bluff côté
Hikaru s'il en a besoin il refera une
petite pause tactique
je vais aller me prendre un petit peu
d'eau
il va rester une demi-heure de jeu
il restera il restera de matchs
un t-shirt iOS et ouais c'est ça
j'ai pas pu bien le voir
il essaye peut-être de s'attirer les
faveurs de l'arbitrage
terrible
ça rend combien de temps je pense vers
18h12
[Musique]
je suppose en tout cas
30 minutes ça fait combien de Game ça
fait 8 9 game deux points c'est beaucoup
des cars en réalité
parce que faut gagner 6 2 c'est un gros
écart
non tu gagnes mais
[Musique]
ouais faut gagner 5 3 pour égaliser 6 2
pour gagner
et ouais ça c'est vraiment là les deux
points d'écart pour Ikaru c'est le par
rapport au contenu des Game c'est le des
parties c'est le meilleur score qui
pouvait espérer avoir
il pouvait pas espérer mieux que plus de
sur les parties il est payé au maximum
c'est pour ça qu'il est pas si serein en
fait parce qu'il domine pas du tout
si on prend le niveau de jeu la même la
chance de pas être en retard je suis
d'accord avec toi dorilo mais bon après
le truc c'est que ikaro sont gros point
fort c'est d'arnaquer défendre donc si
tu lui enlève les positions qu'il
arnaqué qu'il a défendu il va souvent
perdre
donc ça fait partie du jeu mais là je
pense qu'il a arnaqué le maximum qui
pouvait arnaquer en fait
ouais non je pense pas qu'il pouvait qui
pouvait rêver d'un meilleur score à ce
moment du match par rapport à ce qu'on a
vu
joue pas mieux en fait que ni Alain tout
simplement
ça devrait bientôt reprendre on va y
aller qui est en train de revenir
il vient il part
et qui fait ses petits yeux dis carreaux
je peux vous dire que moi j'ai une
caméra dans la salle de NiAl il fait les
400 pas là
on va voir ainsi carreau avec Caroline
il est aussi un petit peu moins fort
comme je le disais depuis quelques
semaines
pas compris Bilou Bilou
pas les rêves
à fond dans le match bah en plus qui est
assez
remarquable dans la gestion du match de
Niall c'est quand vraiment il a perdu
cette partie qui fait passer qui aurait
pu le faire revenir à -2 et où il passe
à moins 4 directement après il a remis
la pression c'était assez impressionnant
il gère vraiment très bien son match
et j'ai l'impression qu'il est plus fort
physiquement en termes de concentration
mais il est jeune aussi donc ceci
explique cela
en tout cas là je peux vous dire qu'il
fait les 400 pagnes il continue à
tourner dans sa pièce
tourner tourner tourne il va peut-être
retourner comme la roue
ça y est il est de retour devant son
ordinateur et ça va pouvoir repartir
ce match est pas du tout fini Maxime ou
bien au contraire bien au contraire
c'est même ni Alain qui s'est mis à
mieux jouer là depuis
40 minutes de 35 minutes de jeu dans le
dans le 3 plus 5 là les dernières 48 de
matchs elles sont complètement à la
faveur de Niall Sarine qui va attaquer
avec les pièces noires en belette c'est
cette première partie va être déjà
déterminante évidemment deux points
d'écart ça peut vite se transformer en
trois ou quatre en quatre victoires
d'icaru qui pourrait faire cavalier seul
après et cette première partie elle est
déjà qu'on double pour Ronal s'il veut
revenir dans le match il faut la gagner
et donc là on a un double fionketto de
part et d'autre évidemment le cavalier a
du mal à faire une découverte en tout
cas quand le cavalier C3 n'était pas là
à cause du mat en G7 et là il Carouge
c'est ce qui fait un il met cette tour
en C5 un peu bizarre NiAl qui a fait un
petit décalage de tête mais l'idée
c'était de battre c'est la dame en 8 le
cavalier qui vient en pour couvrir le
fouger 2 ça s'échange les tours qui
reviennent sur la colonne C NiAl qui va
jouer maintenant pour la case D5 et qui
a l'avantage à la pendule il réussit à
jouer plus vite ni à le Sarine qui
caroue ouais c'est une tornade de Sonia
dame B7 il temporise NiAl qui va
peut-être aller se mettre sur la case
des 5 ces choses faites ça ouvre aussi
le fou bédo passage il défend le pion E7
par tout re 8 NiAl qui joue H4 il prend
de l'espace à l'aile roi il va peut-être
y avoir un H5 10 car ou pour stabiliser
tout ça fout des cas touche la tour la
tour qui va reculer toujours 7 secondes
d'avance pour NiAl qui envoie dame B2 à
tempo qui vient mettre une pression le
long de cette diagonale à 6 et ce qui va
prendre une fond si c'est mettre l'autre
cavaliers pour essayer de faire un
échange non il fait tourcer deux il
laisse B5 quand même il carou qui
réussit ça y est à à se libérer à l'aile
dame cavalier pro FC il échange les
pièces sur échec il va probablement
reprendre du Fou non il prend du
cavalier c'est cloué pour le moment NiAl
qui a l'air d'être un petit peu déçu de
sa position qui est prend des seins qui
a foutranger 7 et B prend ses quatre non
cavalier B4 il va y avoir un décalage de
la tour ou peut-être faut acheter pour
menacer mat non il joue tour des deux
pour le moment attention avec le pouce
en lève ça menacera dame j'ai cette
matière 17 secondes d'avance pour Niall
Sarine à la pendule il met la pression
dès la première partie sur la tête du
carreau ok y a pas l'air bien oh il a
pas l'air bien il a pas l'air bien et là
il va y avoir du foie H6 qui va tomber
F6 et peut-être c'est 5 après pour
rentrer colonne des ça c'est peut-être
ce qui a trouvé pour NiAl c'est pas
facile hein tout de même il faut qu'il
voit le C5 ah le C5 peut faire mal si là
plus que 24 secondes il trouve pas le
coup qu'il a quelque chose il en
position dite du suricate il s'approche
de l'écran est-ce que c'est là qui va
réussir à trouver la la solution non il
fait foi je suis F6 fous prends F6 et
tout reprend des 6 ouais ça ça envoie de
la pièce sans voix la caillasse côté
côté NiAl la dame qui est revenue en G7
pour tout défendre Dame des deux le
cavalier B4 qui est coupé attention il
pourrait y avoir un à trois qui qui
gagne le cheval ici il carou qui a plus
que 6 secondes il carou dans le dur il
carou qui suit ko qui met sa main devant
la bouche il car ok pas bien il Caro qui
pense à Parame ici très clairement et là
il peut y avoir du oh il peut y avoir du
damage 6 il l'a pas vu il l'a pas vu et
là il karaoké proche de la défendre aïe
aïe aïe aïe aïe ça se passe à rien pour
pour NiAl allez faut faire tour B2 allez
peut-être essayer d'aller gagner ces
Punto sur ces cinq à Tours français 5 il
fait un échec en 17 oh il veut jouer
pour le mat mais il y a pas de maths et
Hikaru qui va s'en sortir
de manière hallucinante une nouvelle
fois
qu'elle défense du carreaux c'est
incroyable NiAl qui a raté l'un de
l'inratable et qui laisse filer un
nouveau demi point ouais c'est fou il
aurait vu dans H6 c'était terminé
c'était plié et Karu qui une nouvelle
fois défend l'indéfendable
ah là là là là ça se passe à rien
il avait l'air serein pourtant Hikaru
NiAl pardon et là il Caro qui va jouer
pendant une centaine de coups pour faire
jouer la montre
c'est moche mais c'est très dégueulasse
mais c'est bien joué de la part du
carreau qui joue le temps il utilise de
toutes les ficelles et ouais génial qui
donne la tour et voilà quoi sur quoi ça
se joue
ouais c'est terrible écoeurant c'est que
en mais c'est comme ça
ouais en tournant comme ça ouais il a il
s'est pas rendu compte
c'était extrêmement moche de faire
tourner comme ça mais c'est NiAl qui
rate qui rate sa chance
mais là il a pas fait ça pour arnaquer
car Wan il faisait ça pour pour tourner
jouer un maximum de coups et au passage
il a placé un petit piège
et c'est passé
ouais bon ça se fait absolument pas du
tout mais c'est les règles du
speechestre qui sont un petit peu
particulière
et je pense que malheureusement vu les
cartes qui étaient déjà existant dans le
match
ça va être l'arnaque de trop et une
nouvelle fois c'est une arnaque qui
passe non pas de partie qui aurait dû
gagner ni à la match nul mais de partie
Corée Du gagner à la défaite et il y en
a eu trois des parties comme ça et les
carrés de trois points et c'est vraiment
sur ces choses là que se joue ce match
ça se fait absolument pas mais avant
c'est les règles du speechais qui font
que tout le monde fait ça maintenant
enfin c'est Caro qui a lancé ce truc là
mais oui évidemment ça se fait pas du
tout
simplement comme ça joue sur le temps ce
qu'on fait pas du tout normalement aux
échecs les gens jouent ça pour
temporiser la montre
ça fait partie des règles particulières
entre guillemets de ce speech
qui sont une énième raison pour
lesquelles il faut
un système un petit peu différent
mais bon c'est comme ça
c'est quoi un problème avec cette
technique c'est pas au moins un problème
avec cette technique c'est juste que
dans les échecs quand les positions sont
archives nulles de chez nul comme ça
comme normalement on joue pas en termes
de temps mais en terme de points mais
personne le fait parce que c'est très
irrespectueux mais là de par le format
ça on devient normal enfin
c'est comme ça
on s'en fout un petit peu en même temps
le format avec laqué du coup les gens
les joueurs font des trucs qui sont
claqués
donc
cette position est galère d'être bien
pourri carreau
c'est pas que les fait en deuxième avec
contre Maxime c'était très moche aussi
mais bon c'est le format qui veut ça
c'est les règles qui font que les
joueurs font ça et ça vient pas des
joueurs eux-mêmes enfin juste les règles
font pas de sens et du coup
ce qui est fait ne fait pas de sens non
plus
on essaie de flaguer ton lit mais
n'essayez pas de flaguer Valmy 66 c'est
juste qui joue pour le chronomètre du
truc
il est pas du tout de faire tomber
mais il a pas tant il a pas tenté un
piège non mais c'est pas possible vous
comprenez rien c'est terrifiant
c'est pas un piège il jouait juste pour
pour faire tourner la pendule le maximum
de temps possible
et là il va la gagner
c'est un truc qui n'existe pas
normalement aux échecs en fait ça ça
fait aucun sens
c'est juste la règle particulière de ce
truc là qui fait que les joueurs le font
voilà ça fait plus 4 et c'est terminé
et oui terrible mais mérité un carreau
qui a tellement bien défendu l'écart
était mince mais
un tout petit peu un tout petit peu trop
de déchets NiAl qui était pas loin de
faire le match parfait mais qui ne
réussit pas
là maintenant le match qui retombé comme
un soufflet
première partie de belette qui a fait
mal parce que bah à la fin en fait NiAl
ce qui se passe c'est qu'il s'est rendu
compte que ça allait durer sans coup
donc il a essayé de jouer plus vite
enfin peut-être 150 ou 200 coups donc il
a essayé d'un petit peu et accélérer
pour
pour limiter le temps perdu et il a
oublié que il pouvait perdre la partie
quoi
allez il faut que là il faut qu'il en
gagne deux ou trois d'affilée pour se
redonner une petite chance
j'espère que si Maxime joue contre Caro
il en plaira lui aussi cette année des
suivant final
des techniques à la limite du fair-play
c'est que Maxime un joueur extrêmement
fair-play mais
j'espère que contre Caro il fera il fera
ce qu'il faut faire
play contre les fair-play mais c'est pas
la peine de l'être contre tout le monde
et là c'est dur pour
vraiment très très bon en belette après
la première partie elle a elle a fait
très très mal à la tête de NiAl mais je
pense qui Caro était quand même
légèrement au dessus
quoi qu'il en soit il a déjà plus de
Hello simplement dans la cadence
et là maintenant il semble à l'aise mais
il a été sous pression ikaro dans ce
match quand même
ça pas été un match simple et de tout
repos
mais là maintenant il va attendre c'est
plus 5
ok j'ai 5 c'est bien joué il va prendre
F3 sur échec
et là le match va être clôturé
il va être clôturé voilà c'est la
position est complètement foutue
tente quelques quelques petits trucs
encore
côté NiAl
mais ça va pas aller bien loin le pion
arrive en E3
puis on prend F2 il va peut-être faire
la fin non il va prendre
il va sûrement faire F1 et d'un projet 3
ou dame prend G3 puis F1
la F5 c'est aussi pas mal joué
alors pas pour jouer la finale mais
plutôt
pour taper le roi
NiAl qui défend pas mal quand même
il rentre dans cette finale
le cavalier qui réussit à
couvrir beaucoup de cases intéressantes
il Caro qui s'auto arnaque
et le cavalier qui va réussir à revenir
un peu dégoûté
ah mais elle est peut-être gagnante oh
le bol
regardez la tête et là il y a roi G2 il
est tellement heureux et regarder il
gagne du temps encore c'est hyper malin
il force l'abandon ouais il attendait
encore mais une fois qu'il a trouvé que
c'était gagnant
pour gagner un peu de temps et là ça
fait plus 5 et il reste plus que 17
minutes c'est terminé
il a réussi à faire vraiment tourner le
match sur la défense
mais ouais c'est tellement tellement
difficile de terminer une partie contre
les carreau
tellement difficile
il défend tellement bien c'est
incroyable
on verra si réussi à
l'emporter championnat du monde de Blitz
nikaro qui aimerait bien emporter son
premier titre de champion du monde de
Blitz peut-être cette année
mais là le problème pour Niall c'est que
cette partie là elle va durer un temps
va attendre voilà il refait un peu comme
il a fait dans la partie où il a arnaqué
il va pas prendre trop trop de temps
parce que c'est possible de jouer mais
il va faire tourner la pendule
il utilise c'est plus 5 là
en fait c'est dans un cas de figure
similaire que ni à la craquer tout à
l'heure en dans la première partie en
voulant essayer de trouver comment faire
nulle vite
et pour éviter d'avoir une centaine de
coups comme ça
il y a pas une limite de coups 50
donc il va faire 50 coups comme ça
donc là il réattend un peu
pour réussir à faire tourner au maximum
la pendule
c'est comme c'est pour c'est ça c'est ce
truc là qui a fait craquer tout à
l'heure
il essayait pas de l'arnaquer en fait il
essayait de faire ça et KO et au passage
à une arnaque au hasard qui est tombée
qui fait quand même semblant de
réfléchir et de pas faire un truc
d'enfoiré c'est ça qui est magnifique
mais après c'est complètement légal
c'est le format qui veut ça
là c'est complètement fermé ouais ouais
personne peut faire de
de percer
ce qui est beau c'est qu'il fait quand
même de l'acting en faisant semblant qui
réfléchit alors que là il réfléchit
absolument pas
c'est ça qui est beau
ce serait mieux des BO plutôt que du
temps ah bah oui il a attendu vraiment
le 50e coup jusqu'au bout
de toute façon on s'est fait c'est un
jeu qui est fait les échecs de par son
système de comptage c'est un jeu qui est
fait pour avoir un système de jeu et 7
comme au tennis ou au ping-pong ou au
volley
mais pas qui est pas fait pour pour
avoir ce système de comptage de par la
nature du jeu en fait
mais il a raison de faire ça icaru
c'est autorisé et ça c'est assez
pragmatique il a il a raison de le faire
il essaye de gagner un maximum de temps
en fait c'est le
c'est le format qui fait absolument
aucun sens mais ce que font les joueurs
tu les fais jouer dans des formats qui
font juste 0 enfin qui sont idiots en
fait donc topiens des résultats idiots
mais faut pas blâmer car ou pour ça
c'est comme le fait que tu dois jouer
les matchs jusqu'au bout enfin ouais non
mais c'est le format qui va pas du tout
c'est pareil carreau
fais jouer dans un format comme ça tu
que c'est pas mal joué
tu peux pas tu peux pas faire autrement
ok bon il y a plus trop d'enjeux je
pense 11 minutes
là c'est complètement pli ado
je crois que c'est mathématiquement plié
signal gagne il est encore une petite
chance il gagne pas je crois il y a
vraiment plus aucune chance mathématique
de rien
il va pas la gagner celle-là
ah mais à 5 points d'écart ah oui non
c'est plié je croyais que on avait il y
avait que 4 points ouais 5 points c'est
plié
il y aura pas 5 parties ici
matinarable
il a même pas joué le coup qu'il aurait
d'habitude il joue un coup quand même
ce qui se passe pour ikaro
qu'est-ce qu'il fait ah c'est du 5 + 1
il y a eu un bug
mauvaise cadence il y a eu un bug
étonnant
et ça gratte du temps ouais puisque le
chronomètre a continué à tourner
malin on sait pas si c'est Hikaru qui a
réussi à
un match en 5 + 1
le temps qui a été remis
mais bon là de toute façon quatre
parties ayant normalement ils ont
encore un petit monde où il revient
mais très franchement si ça joue encore
pendant 7 8 heures ça se peut qu'il y a
les finissent par prendre le dessus
parce que j'ai l'impression qu'il y a
une super condition physique
on va voir
je pense pas je pense pas qu'il y a
encore je pense c'est fini
mathématiquement
parce qu'il reste 8 minutes ouais
il y aura pas 4 game en tout cas beau
match en les enseignements à tirer c'est
quand même qui Caro est prenable déjà
si on en était pas sûr
ni à la montrer que c'était stefaisable
après il faut vraiment réaliser le match
parfait et éviter vraiment quand on se
fait arnaquer de perdre
c'est ça surtout je pense l'enseignement
à tirer c'est Ikaru il en défendra des
positions parce qu'il défend mieux que
tout le monde mais faut vraiment essayer
de pas complètement glisser et pas de se
faire arnaquer au point de perdre
futur très grand écoute j'en sais rien
pour moi un match sur Internet ne veut
absolument rien dire donc
ce match n'a aucune valeur au-delà de
ouais je sais pas comment dire en fait
donc ouais je prends pas trop en compte
les matchs internet mais il a très bien
joué ça c'est sûr
il a fait un très bon match ça c'est sûr
là c'est dur F5
et va clôturer ce match une bonne fois
pour toute
dame à 7 ou un truc comme ça
ça a l'air vraiment fort
ça ça doit être gagnant maintenant la
dame noire et passive
OK
défend pas mal encore NiAl
mais bon
façon il reste
il faudrait qu'il la gagne et la gagner
c'est pas possible et même si il a gagné
ce serait quand même probablement fini
mathématiquement
et ça y est on est vraiment sûr on était
déjà sur mes matchs terminaux
on va attendre 5 minutes pour être bien
sûr mais là c'est fini mathématiquement
pour et même se lever se barrer de
l'ordi qui perdrait qu'il aurait gagné
le match et Caro
on se retrouvera de nous demain
pour le match de Maxime contre Magnus
qui a fait une énorme performance
voilà c'est ça rime qui a les blancs je
suis du mauvais côté désolé je suis un
peu en roue libre aussi
évidemment plus sympa pour nous le match
de demain avec Maxime
l'affiche est globalement plus belle de
toute façon
tu as deux champions du monde qui
s'affrontent demain
champion du monde de cadence longues
contre le championnat du monde de
cadence Blitz duel de champion du monde
demain
c'est vraiment le match de gala par
excellence
même et le score va pas là il est elle
qui va encore mettre un point
le score va jamais vraiment enfler
NiAl quand même dominé dans les bullets
évidemment
ouais ça va dame j'ai 6 ça va pas être
facile dans le pas chez le mat ouais bon
il fait ça comme ça
il restera encore une game derrière
ah et malin qui a valait ses trois avec
du cavalier de échec mais c'est ça la
force du carreaux c'est qu'il a toujours
un coup de plus
dans son sac
ouais mais c'est
gagnant mais c'est facile à gagner même
mais tu devais pas ça devait pas être
aussi long en fait comme partie a gagné
c'est vraiment tout le match il te fait
chier
c'est vraiment impressionnant
bon allez il va jouer jusqu'au bout pour
faire tourner le chrono maximum
ça c'est la technique icaru
et il va laisser tourner les 50 secondes
voilà et là il va attendre 50 secondes
ça il le fait à chaque fois
c'est vraiment pour être bien sûr c'est
bien joué de la part du carreau de faire
ça
même si la match gagnait à 100% même si
c'est terminé il le fait quand même
pour vraiment être sûr
c'est très très bien fait de sa part
professionnel dans tous ces petits
tricks il avait été aussi au moment où
il a pas remarche il a réussi à faire
temporiser le match une minute 30
récupérer
et là encore
[Musique]
il utilise tous les tous les petits
trucs en son pouvoir
c'est très très malin même si le match
est gagné à 100% qui sait qui peut pas
remonter que c'est déjà fini on utilise
quand même le trick et il va quand même
jouer le coup droit ouais pour gagner
encore quand même une demi seconde c'est
très très fort
c'est très malin
et ça il le refrain en finale contre
Maxime au contraire ou contre Magnus il
en a la possibilité
c'est très très bien joué
bel exemple qu'il faudra que Maxime
suive un si je joue contre lui faudra
pas être gentil dès le début du match si
Maxime peut pourrir le match il faudra
le faire il faudra pourrir ce match à
fond
prendre le taureau par les cornes
il joue extrêmement bien avec les règles
et il a raison
les règles ne changent pas donc autant
profiter
j'espère que Magnus fera pareil mais je
pense pas je pense que ma nuit il ira
juste de l'humilier en lui mettant un
gros score
il a une autre manière de d'agir Magnus
ça va plus être
dans le score qui enflait mais ce sera
pas Magnus
donc il a fait fou et le 5
donc le match va être terminé
et ça y est le match est fini alors moi
quand le match sera terminé je vais tout
de suite vous envoyer sur chaise
pour pour que vous ayez les interviews
qu'à leur demain 19h
ouais ça ça va faire nul
4 points d'écart ouais c'est pas
franchement
c'est pas énorme
il y aura un commentaire avec toi non
pas demain
ça c'est nul facile mais de toute façon
la partie est anecdotique
quoi que ouais est-ce que si facile
carreau qui a dû penser que ça faisait
nul sans réfléchir
ça doit pas être si compliqué mais bon
elle est le roi monte quand même le roi
vivant des quatre
il faudrait 6 tours 2
comme une partie qu'on a suivi plus tôt
pour 3 ou 4 on reprend le 2 et ça va
faire nul avec le pion h
et ça fait nul par pattes quatre points
d'écart et ben écoutez merci d'avoir
suivi ce live et ce match en ma
compagnie on se retrouve demain pour le
match entre mvl et Magnus Carlsen merci
à vous passez une bonne soirée ciao ciao
[Musique]